e
so good morning
everybody I'm always the last one in the
room I apologize fourth term what are
you going to do um well it's great to
see everybody we're uh well it's kind of
we just finished our legislative session
as a lot of folks know uh but here in
New Hampshire I guess the work is never
done right so we are jumping right into
the budget process and we always kick
things off uh with our the capital
aspect of the budget process um not to
go into any long winded speeches um
other than the capital as a lot of folks
know the capital budget process is very
different than our uh operational budget
we'll bring in that process and have
those hearings as well uh I think those
will happen in December is that November
in November shortly after the election
um and as just taking up some questions
I received early this morning uh from
the Press uh I think there was a
surprise that yes we begin the capital
the capital budget process and the um
General budget process uh because you
can't do the whole thing in two months
uh with with the new um incoming uh
governor and and administration uh
obviously the Department of administr
Services the legislative body all the
the LBA all the folks that really have
to get involved in most importantly all
the different departments that we'll
present here uh specifically on these
processes um they're integral there's a
lot to to uh review to analyze to look
at both in terms of Revenue projections
and opportunities as well as
understanding where the real uh biggest
priorities needs and even sometimes in
the best of times where some of the
wants are uh and we can uh kind of make
progress on some of the new initiatives
that that we bring out capital budget is
uh we start with this one uh it's a
little more straightforward which I
don't want to say it makes it easier
there's still some very tough decisions
to be made um the state typically
approves somewhere between 120 and 130
million dollar of of capital budget
expenditures as part of the capital
budget my sense is um that's that's
right where we should be and that's not
just uh from what I think it's it's
talking to the state treasurer
understanding uh the fiscal uh health of
the State uh how much debt we typically
take on because this is debt that we're
talking about uh and where the the needs
are now there are always a lot of needs
in the state Technically when it comes
to the capital budget we're very frugal
and that's always a good thing here in
New Hampshire but it does and it has
meant traditionally I'd say over the
past 30 to 40 years that our physical
infrastructure does deteriorate it does
need a lot of Maintenance it does need a
lot of upkeep and upgrade um we have had
a lot of opportunity with uh the federal
money that has come in in a variety of
different forms both the transportation
Bill the arpa funds even a little bit of
the KAC funds not as much there um the
December 2020 uh appropriation that was
passed out out of Congress these have
all provided a lot of uh infrastructure
money in a lot of different ways uh I
think Charlie uh and commissioner Arling
housee and his Department have have done
a very good job working with the fiscal
committee I think making some pretty
aggressive um uh investments into our
our Capital um one of the biggest
Investments you can see is a big hole of
right across the street right because
the our elas attorney general has just
walked in and he didn't walk across the
street today um um so we have had some
some pretty significant Capital
opportunity in the state that's been
great and and if one of the uh
interesting aspects is if anything one
of the things we have heard is we
departments have come to us and said you
know what right now we we have needs but
we can't take on another Capital project
because there is a lot of Manpower uh
that goes into that whether it's the
Contracting process the assessment
process the uh kind of that Clerk of the
works managing those projects as they
come to fruition um I see um
commissioner Stewart in the back uh
Parks has take on a lot of capital
investment and it's great um and also
folks have to understand that what we
talk about today in this hearing and as
the process goes on um it still can
evolve a bit because sometimes you say
we're going to take on these 10 projects
but you know what one of the 10 but one
reason or another just can't come to
fruition it's a supply chain issue and
and we need to Pivot so we always want
to build in some flexibility there um
given the the kind of tough times in
terms of both pricing uh and supply
chain that that we still have and likely
will have um so uh this year we received
requests for just shy of$ 1.3 billion of
projects 1.3 billion
um it is a lot so we're just going to
toss those up and take the first 10% we
pull out of the hat and then we can all
go home and and that maybe that's the
the easiest way to do it I'm not going
to do that don't worry
um so 1.1 billion of that 1.3 billion
because this some federal money that can
be included in there other funds fees
Tech sometimes from places like fish and
game whatever it might be but about 1.1
billion of that the that 1.3 billion uh
would technically be repaid out of the
general fund which is the the the
significant part of the consideration um
so therefore as I just discussed we're
looking I guess technically about 10% of
the total request uh will likely and
hopefully be approved through the
legislature over the past few years
we've allocated close to a billion a
billion of arpa funds uh in a ways and
mostly in infrastructure we we really
tried to do our best to make sure we
weren't spending our AR dollars on
long-term obligations so as we didn't
put the state in a in in a tougher hole
down the
road uh we had about $800 million in
Surplus spending over the past couple
budgets as well so a lot of money and a
lot of opportunity um have really been
been put out there uh and so we'll add
to that look again looking somewhere in
the realm of$ 120 to $130 million in
capital projects through this budget
process the en Hamp economy is strong
and I think a lot of folks realize that
I think inflation is is around to stay I
try to remind folks that while inflation
may only be down to 3 or 4% that's still
on top of the 25% of compounded
inflation that we've experienced over
the past 3 or four years that's very
real so in a sense what we were paying
for things in 2020 at a minimum I mean
in some areas of construction it's well
beyond 30 40 50% but in in in at a
minimum we're still looking at 25 to 30%
increases over what we were paying just
a few years ago and and what I've
learned is going through all these
different projects with vendors with the
private sector is there is a um there's
a cultural adjustment mindset that has
to be we're still not there right we
still like to hope that things are going
to cost X and then we we come back and
and the prices a little higher to the
credit of dot to the folks at Das the a
lot of the folks at Public Works I think
a lot of those inflationary adjustments
have been made and we try to put make
sure we instill them into our
engineering
estimates um to make sure that we're
we're not over or under budgeting I
always say that um some people say oh
under budgeting is is okay because you
have money left over it's not you want
to be the best budgeting is a budget
that is right on target um because that
ensures that you didn't miss
opportunities you didn't waste
opportunities and you didn't overpromise
and under underd deliver at the same
time um in terms of just the general
revenues although it doesn't directly
apply to um the capital budget uh
because these you know we're going to
likely be borrowing this money um there
is interest to be paid um I think what
you'll see and and it'll be a deeper
discussion as we get into the more
general part of the the budget process
uh later this fall but what you're
likely going to see is a is a much more
traditional level of revenues coming
into the state we've had some very good
years but I think as folks have realized
because of the change in Workforce
Dynamics how businesses are uh
consolidating and and how they're
operating profits are strong and that's
good that provides a lot of fiscal
opportunity to the state
uh Workforce is there but not like it
was and that obviously affects our
business Enterprise tax which is
significantly down across the state so
while we have had the luxury of of um I
won't say luxury um we I think we work
very hard to earn our luxury to make
sure we've had surpluses over the past
few years my sense is that this will the
incoming budget will be a much tougher
budget um I'm not saying losses per se
um but we're not going to have the the
giant surpluses I think that we've we've
had in the past few years uh both part
because of our strong New Hampshire
economy but also because of the the help
and assistance from uh from the federal
side on specifically on these capital
projects uh so any project that does go
into the capital budget um we just have
to make sure it truly is necessary uh
for the ongo ongoing operations for the
department and agency um and by
necessary it could be in issues of
health and safety um it could be you
know we don't want roofs falling in we
don't want dangerous situations for our
employees for the citizens of the state
as they are work in our facilities uh or
work through our facilities um uh what
whatever it might be um the the there's
obviously the word I would tell all
Commissioners don't don't use the term
nice to have it's not a good term to use
um we all have things that are nice to
have um these are really about needs um
for your department for your employees
and for the customers uh and the
citizens that rely on the agencies uh to
make sure that that they're coming
through um so as again just to go
through the the timeline a little bit
here uh we're going to start out I think
think uh we traditionally have all the
different departments come up before
over a period of is it two days we do a
day and a a day and a half a day and a
half or so um we I think we Alla always
traditionally start off with the
university system of New Hampshire um
and seeing as this is our fourth time
around we're not going to break from
tradition with that um that'll be
followed by the Department of Justice
education the Community College there'll
be a small lunch break later on there'll
be a half a dozen or so agencies uh this
afternoon and then I I believe another
half dozen or so tomorrow morning uh
right back here at 9:00 a.m. again um so
this is where I kind of look around the
room and I figure out did I did I cover
what I need to cover you did we're good
we're good great and I apologize I
didn't introduce uh James Gary um uh my
budget director uh for those who don't
know James will be driving the both the
capital budget and operational budget
process uh from here until January 3rd
or whenever whenever they kick me out of
here um because it is a pretty intense
process and obviously we'll work very
closely with the next Administration
either way on both the capital budget
and our current and operational budget
General budget process uh just to make
sure that it's seamless um and um and as
smooth as possible for both the
Departments and especially the
legislator as you know new legislators
uh come into the process uh as well we
just want to uh provide as much
continuity uh as we can but with that I
guess we I'll invite the university Sy
of New Hampshire to come on up uh for
good morning Governor tunu members of
the committee my name is Kathy prenter
I'm the incoming Chancellor of our
state's University system and
congratulations commissioner earling
house on your
reappointment um we do have a a few
slides I'm not going to walk through all
of these Bill Janelle and mat Perell
with me this morning to answer any
questions specific to the projects that
we're requesting funding for at UNH
plumouth and Kean um $1.1 billion doll
in requests that's a lot we we have
submitted respectfully a request for $20
million in the upcoming
bium um in 2019 the capital budget was
written to provide three bium uh of
Appropriations for the University system
that was exceptionally helpful in our
planning and um we would very much like
to have that discussion in in the
upcoming bium for for three bium I just
want to highlight a few things before
getting into specifics about the
University Systems Capital plan we spent
about a $100 million a year on Capital
about 75% of that is from University
system funds about 10% from State funds
and then the balance comes from gifts
and grants we have 8.8 million gross
square feet of space across our all of
our campuses plus all the infrastructure
utilities um the replacement cost on
that is about 2.9 billion so we're we
have you know three little towns or
cities if you will that that we're um
running and responsible for the state
component of our Capital plan is a
critical component and we very much
appreciate the support and partnership
that we've had with the state over the
years and supporting our Capital plan um
one more thing before we get into any
more details um you may know that the
university system does not have
authority to bond for any of its
academic space we bond for
self-supporting dorms res Halls dining
Halls uh so the the
vast majority of the dollars that the
university system invests is in fact
from our um resources we generally
budget one times
depreciation for deferred maintenance
the um we we are not looking to expand
our footprint at all we are actually
intentionally trying to right size and
reduce because our student population is
declining um we are are selling
properties we are demolishing properties
but we also have deferred maintenance
needs and that's specific to the the
requests that we're making for UNH
Plymouth and
Kean and honestly with that unless you
have questions for me I'd like Bill and
Matt to talk about the projects that
we're seeking State support and
partnership on so okay thank you Kathy
morning Governor sunu members of the
committee uh unh's top priority for
Capital funding is replacement of the
HVAC system in mors Hall um and on slide
six there's a little quick background of
Morse Hall so Morse Hall is the home for
the institute for the study of Earth's
oceans and space uh it was constructed
in 1986 it's a four-story building about
131,000 Square ft and it's mainly uh the
building where where the majority of our
campus again we're looking to replace
the building wide HVAC equipment uh we
hope to reduce operating costs and an
important key is we need to be able to
maintain temperature and humidity
tolerances in this building and uh in
order to uh many of the grants that we
get require those tolerances be
maintained so that's really the priority
of what we're trying to do here but
we're also trying to modernize the Fume
hoods that are in there uh improve
safety and functionality and Energy
Efficiency and seal up the envelope as
well uh on slide eight just gives you a
sense of the system we're working with
it's 38 years old we're holding it
together so really this is a deferred
maintenance
project um and again the laboratory
spaces that we have which are the
majority of this building uh we have
difficulty maintaining temperature and
humidity tolerances and much of the
research work that we do are through
federal grants groups like NASA uh they
bring teams in and inspect the building
while we're doing the work so if we're
not within those tolerances the work
needs to stop and uh our concern is if
that if we can't do that then we won't
receive the grants any
longer and then uh the budget for the
project we we haven't completely
finalized the design at this point but
we're looking between 23 and $25
million uh and again to 50% of the
research at UNH happens within moris
Hall and in 23 we received $100 million
in research grants and on average we
receive 60 million in research grants um
so again this project will work to keep
you good morning I'm Matt purcel
director Capital planning and
development for the University system in
New Hampshire going to just briefly
touch on two of the projects that we
have at Keenan Plymouth uh the first one
at Plymouth is the renovation of Hyde
Hall Hyde Hall is their primary academic
facility on the campus it's the home for
their Innovation and entrepreneurial
cluster um it's the building itself is
about 81,000 Square ft and since its
construction in
1974 uh you know haven't been able to
keep up and replace the infrastructure
within that building to the point that
we've had failures of their uh
ventilation systems and you know there's
never been any air conditioning in the
building and it was poorly in no little
to no insulation and uh those are part
of the projects that we're trying as
part of the maintenance for that
building to rectify um it's currently in
the process of being renovated we're
currently in the construction phase of
that project that project is going to
extend for another year and a half um
some of that is some of that is due to
the supply chain other is due to the
fact that we're we're trying to do this
in an occupied building so it makes more
sense to do a lot of it as you know not
what we call Summers Slammers but more
predominantly the work is happening in
the building when it's when it's empty
uh the total as I mentioned the total
project Bud budget is about $30.5
million and um you know a major portion
of that is being made up with you know
uh funding from a variety of different
sources primarily from the from the
campus
itself second project I want to just
talk about briefly is at Keem State
College this is the renovation of the
Elliott Center the Elliot Center is a is
the former city of Kean hospital that
was acquired by Keen State College in
1972 it houses a number of student
support services and again a a
tremendous amount over $20 million worth
of deferred maintenance currently exists
in that building
um and what we're proposing on this
project is to focus on dealing with a
lot of those deferred maintenance
projects um we had originally talked
about um redoing a lot of the student
services and collecting them there but
based on the master planning process
that we just went through we've decided
to kind of refocus some of the energies
within that building to some other
student support um programs than the uh
what in there now um there's buildings
about 93,000 ft and the proposed project
will deal with a lot of the uh failing
Heating and ventilation systems that are
in the building right now and then also
we had a lot of uh due to co we kind of
move some of the program out of that
building and this project would kind of
revitalize some of those core building
pieces that are now sitting um you know
vacant and reutilizing those spaces
uh total project cost that we're looking
at is about $15 million of which we're
going to deal hopefully with at least
four million if not more in deferred
[Music]
project we wanted to make sure we leave
plenty of time for questions um should
you have any and um this is just like I
said a sampling of the multitude
projects deferred maintenance projects
that we have are ongoing um on our
campuses great well thank you very much
thee yes because as Matt mentioned Hyde
is well into construction and we've also
had to phase the Hyde project over a
number of years because of the dollars
we only have so many dollars so but it
is it it is in Full Construction so um
yes that's the number one priority to
finish
that um you you mentioned that you
received over over the three different
bium the the capital funding uh in
addition to that I know in the last
budget you received $6 million for the
for the Center uh for upgrades
there could you just briefly explain uh
in light of inflation and supply chain
issues and things that we've experienced
over the last six years uh how those
projects are going just a brief overview
and what what problems you run into with
those so let me talk about the so in the
last this past six years it the big ones
were Spalding and um bill can talk to
that that's almost complete
Hyde was also we also received some
funding for Hyde Hall that's ongoing we
have costs are higher than we
initially
um when we initially had the design the
costs have gone up but we made a
commitment to the state we were not
coming back and asking for more
money it back in 2019 that any overages
the university system would be
responsible for um and Bill can also
talk to status of the wi y so the
Spalding Hall project biological
sciences initiative that was our last
request for the last three banum um it's
just being completed now we just
received our uh certificate of occupancy
actually last week uh there were some
budget changes initially when we started
that project but once we brought our CM
on board and got into construction we've
been able to hold to the budget uh
dollar amount so it it's come in uh
where we expected but $95 million um so
that project has gone fairly well we
have seen some supply chain challenges
with electrical equipment HVAC
equipment um
Transformers as well I mean we do our
best to try to plan these projects ahead
of time and if we need to buy that
equipment early early on just to have it
uh so it's ready for the construction
sequence we do that wherever we can um
so that you know it's it's still a
challenge but that's how we try to deal
with it you know project by project
basically um as far as the Whitmore
Center goes it's currently in the design
phase right now so and we also just
issued the RFP for construction
management services so that's on the
street right now as well and we
anticipate starting construction in the
spring and finishing right now a year
later but we'll know more as we go
through the design phase okay uh one one
last followup when when you when you
priced out these uh projects uh given
that the the first available ility of
this money is going to be July 1st of of
25 uh did you price these projects based
on the price now or what it is
anticipated to
be uh next summer and this summer and
fall of
2025 yeah they're based on the
anticipated pricing so what's built into
the construction cost estimate is an
escalation contingency so we so we
factor out into the middle of the
project with that escalation contingency
and that's included in the cost
estimates that we develop
okay great thank
you just a brief question the chancellor
mentioned that you're downsizing that
you're you didn't say unloading
properties but um something like that
well one next week
right actually I think two next week oh
two next week um I I wondered if if if
your footprint is shrinking on your
campuses it may not be shrinking much um
somewhere in the back of my mind I'm
thinking of the uh you may be aware that
housing is a challenge in the state of
New Hampshire lately um have you looked
at I I know there are places across the
country and maybe even in our own state
where people looked at converting
buildings like old dorms or buildings
that can be retrofitted into uh you know
you couldn't you couldn't sell one of
your buildings so operating business but
you know housing at the edge of Campus
you could convert to housing has there
been any looking at that I know that's
not that's off capital budget but
actually the conversations are happening
we're in early
stages um possibly at Plymouth at
Plymouth we are seriously looking at a
number of different facilities there
converting that we have on the campus
that are some of them are the old houses
that we're turning into Workforce
housing Another We're actually looking
at one of the resident Halls of turning
it into a senior living facility as well
with a developer oh very interesting
okay thank you
any further questions no okay well thank
you guys we appreciate your time thank
you very much we appreciate your time
thanks and the the last page is contact
information as always if anyone has any
followup questions you can contact me
directly or Lauren Banker our director
of government relations so have a great
day
thank yeah one of the uh one one of the
disadvantages of having a very popular
Governor his demands on his schedule are
very high and so I I I've sworn to the
chief of staff that I keep him on his
schedule so the governor has to leave
so okay uh continuing on with the
Department of Justice Mr Attorney
General
yes good morning Mr budget director
commissioner and all members of the
committee uh for the record John fella
attorney general and I'm joined here
this morning by David portal he's our it
manager he's going to take the lead on
this presentation but I'll just I'll
start us off um first of all let me just
assure you that we are not looking for a
new build building or anything related
to construction lest we be thrown out
after the first 30 seconds uh we are
here requesting funding for a new case
management system and David will will
explain that but but our case management
system is what we use in the Department
of Justice really in many ways to run
our lives to to store documents um to to
work collaboratively on projects to
segment off cases the way they should be
segmented off to wall people off from
cases they shouldn't have access to and
to you know to allow multiple lawyers to
edit the same document at the same time
to you know to keep scheduling to be
able to put emails quickly into into a
document management system as as many
people know the practice of law involves
managing and saving and organizing a lot
of documents and when we're working on
cases with with such high stakes to the
state it's really important that we have
a good document management system so
with that I'm going to turn it over to
David um just a little bit about David
he joined us about a year ago came to us
from Florida he's done an amazing job um
he decided to join an attorney general's
office right before it moved to a new
space which you as you can imagine
presented a lot of various it challenges
if you get a lot of lawyers paralegals
investigators and other types of
professionals who work in an AG's office
to have to pick up their technology and
move it to a new place as you can
imagine that raises a lot of questions
complaints issues and D David has been
great in helping us manage that and
great in helping lead this project and
he's just done an amazing job all around
so with that I'm going to turn it over
to him to go through the presentation
but I'll of course be here as well to
help answer questions um and of course I
don't want to be remiss to my right is
also Kathy Carr director of
administration uh but David's going to
be leading the presentation so that's
why I'm giving D David the spotlight so
with that I will turn it over to to you
David thank you very much John um and
thank you for the uh introduction as
well um just to reiterate my name is
David portal um I'm the it manager of
the unire Department of Justice um I
handle the day-to-day infrastructural
needs um of the doj in tandem with
doit um and I've been in this role for
almost a year uh one of my main goals um
in this role uh has been to replace our
case management system so we're going to
jump straight into it um if you can move
to the next slide um
so first we're going to qualify what a
case management system actually is a
case management system is a piece of
software that allows law firms and legal
entities to store access and edit files
and information related to cases this
information uh can include things like
case numbers Personnel information
outcomes and litigation information just
to name a few um the case management
system is just a piece of software that
interacts with a database in our case
it's a Microsoft SQL Server datab datase
uh that is hosted in uh in a basement at
Hazen drive by our wonderful Department
of it um they have expressed to us and
this is a sentiment that we concur with
that they do not want to be hosting our
server for too much longer because of
the potential security risks with having
the server be in their basement um if
anything were to happen a data breach um
any kind of theft of data then they
would be responsible and um we would not
want that either so part of this project
would also include moving our database
uh to a cloud um so
um next up the uh case management
systems are the main file cabinets and
uh work environments for Department of
Justice employees um so this isn't just
a repository that we just dump files
into and forget about um our attorneys
and paralal have our case management
system up 100% the time and they're
constantly working within it um the case
management system has uh useful tools
like uh timekeeping billing and
Reporting so again just to reiterate
that it's not just a place that we dump
files into um our Medicaid fraud control
unit grants management unit uh
charitable trusts and Environmental
Protection Bureau they all make use of
the billing functionality in praw and or
sorry I got ahead of myself pra is our
current case management system um they
currently make use of the billing
functionality of our current case
management system uh and they have also
expressed that they would like to see
some better functionality for this um
the reporting functionality of a case
management system is also very important
um specifically for our Medicaid fraud
control unit and tradable Trust units um
they uh the reporting functionality of a
case management system allows them to
generate reports and meet federal
reporting standards um so now that I've
qualified what a case management system
actually is we are going to move on to
our current case management
system so our current case management
system is called praw it is a Thompson
Reuters uh product um the New Hampshire
Department of Justice acquired praw in
2004 for $1.2 million that's $2 million
today adjusting for inflation um over
the last 20 years the New Hamshire
department of justice has paid for
various upgrades to praw they're they
vary in size but for the most part um
these upgrades are just to keep prolow
running with modern case management or
with modern operating systems and modern
server Hardware um and between support
Personnel licenses and server Hardware
uh the doj spends roughly $400,000 a
year on praw um so we have a contractor
for backend under thehood support um
whenever structural change needs to be
made to praw um or if there are any
catastrophic issues with it um and they
also collaborate with doit to help
manage the database um they also help
with day-to-day tech support and
answering and with answering questions
um so now I'm going to move on to why we
need to replace PR law if we can move to
the next
slide
so simply put and this is the main
message we want to convey to you is that
uh PR is at the end of its lifespan uh
it's in legacy mode which means that it
is no longer getting updates and it will
eventually stop working entirely as
Microsoft SQL software uh gets more
advanced and as um as operating system
get more advanced um currently we're
kind of navigating Rocky Waters as doit
wants to um move the state of New
Hampshire to Windows 11 um in 2025 and
it's still unsure as to whether PR law
is actually going to work on Windows
11 um so PR law also lacks many features
that are baselined for modern Case
Management Systems again prola met the
doj's needs back in 2004 but in the year
2024 Case Management Systems have gotten
pretty Advanced um so these systems uh
include plain text searching so uh
currently with our current case
management system if we wanted to look
up um all documents that had the word
giraffe in them for example uh we can't
do that um prologist doesn't allow you
to do that whereas modern case
management systems do uh in fact we have
to pay for an additional piece of
software from another vendor in order to
give us that functionality um prola also
lacks eisc Discovery tools um and it
also lacks the ability to share cases
with outside Council and share limited
database access with outside Council um
so that's enough about prola um let's
move on to uh the benefits of a new case
management
system so a new case management system
would result in increased workflow
efficiency for doj employees um these
newer case management systems such as e
prosecutor prosecutor by carpel and
legal file
um they all include built-in workflow
management tools um with such as inapp
messaging and automated workflow
Solutions so for example if there's a a
claims process going on um there's
automated tools to move that claim along
to who it needs to go to and we don't
have to be emailing documents uh back
and forth within each other and with um
outside Council
um an additional uh benefit would be
enhanced database security so um like I
mentioned before we would be moving this
new uh database over to um a government
Cloud uh this would be a Fed ramp and
state ramp um certified Cloud it's not
just some random server that we picked
off somewhere random um so doit would no
longer have to worry about maintaining
the security of our database uh which is
a huge Plus for them we again we
currently pay doit for um database
hardware and for maintenance of that
database um the costs of
um and we're going to get into this
later but the costs of um a hosted
solution as opposed to paying do for
this solution they'd be roughly the same
anyway um and then another um another
benefit to a new case management system
would be the potential to cut other
software from our budget like I
mentioned earlier uh we pay for certain
pieces of software like um perceptive
search um and we pay for another piece
of software called everlaw for ecovery
uh and we pay a not insignificant amount
of money for them um we could
potentially cut those pieces of software
out of our budget if um we were to get a
newer more robust case management system
that has those features baked into it um
so now we're going to get on to the part
that you are all interested in which is
the cost of a new case management system
um so the doj estimates uh roughly $2.2
million for a completely new cloud-based
case management system uh this includes
initial implementation from a vendor and
uh 3 years of startup support so that
includes uh training testing maintenance
um and user licenses as well um this
would also include a database transfer
of 20 years of case history um moving a
200 terabyte database from um theit's
basement to a Cloud Server uh is not a
small undertaking at all um so we would
be paying for for the amount of work
required in that as well um so this is
consistent with what other state AG's
offices have paid for their case
management systems and um storage will
likely on the high end cost about
$223,200 per year but there is room for
lowering it as um if we go with a hosted
solution we could archive certain pieces
of data so let's say if we have cases
from 2004 2005 that we know we're not
going to need we can just archive those
cases and pay a fraction of the money
for for the amount of space that they
take up on the database um and
year-to-year costs to maintain the
system are estimated to be the same as
PR law maintenance which um as I said
before was uh about $400 a year it it
varies depending on if we need uh have a
major upgrade implemented or not um and
that is it for us um if any of you have
any
questions yes thank you uh two two quick
questions uh one is what is the average
or the expected useful life for the
project and the second is what is the
total of Maintenance you mentioned the
223,000 for storage but additional costs
right that you're going to need as far
as software Manpower things like that to
maintain the the system so useful life
and ongoing maintenance right so um the
projected lifespan I mean our our
current case management system it lasted
US 20 years by the end of of its
lifespan it's going to last us uh it's
going to be about 24 25 years we're
hoping that this that a new a brand new
case management system will last us
equally as long um a benefit here is
that um if we were to go with a cloud
hosted solution um a lot of modern Case
Management Systems have uh browser
access um so it's not just a program
that you just install onto your computer
you can just open up your web browser
and then get onto the um get onto the
the software uh which is useful because
updates are much smaller deal in that
case um so it could last upwards of 20
years maybe more I'm um currently it
depends on the solution that we go with
obviously if we go with a solution
that's been in the market for quite a
while now then it probably won't last as
long but if we go with a newer solution
then there's a higher chance of it
lasting longer um and then in terms of
the money spent um uh year-over-year on
praw um specifically in terms of
Maintenance um that that comes in the
form of uh server space it also comes in
the form of paying support Personnel um
and and um we had also had to pay for
training as well um and we also pay for
user licenses too uh we have roughly 200
user licenses that we pay for um I
believe it's on a yearly basis okay do
you know what that would add up to what
you're projecting that to be that adds
up to about 400,000 okay so it's pretty
much the same as you're it breaks yes
okay that's yeah thank
you I have a I have a question and first
of all it's nice to uh it's nice that
the IT guy at Justice is named Mr portal
I was thinking about making a joke about
that like you're an accountant named
Donna debbit um so I appreciate that um
uh a couple a couple of questions the
2.2 million is I presume The onetime
Upfront cost and does not include
licensing um it does include licensing
for the first three years Perpetual
instead of annual um no they are annual
licenses um so this 2.2 million figure
it covers the implementation costs and
all support in licensing for 3 years for
three years and then what's the what's
the annualized licensing cost after that
um um it it's going to depend on the
solution itself we don't project it to
be more than um our our current case
management system um if and if it is
it's probably not by money oh so and
like the 400,000 you spend annually that
includes that includes the LIC includes
licensing and so that wouldn't change um
I did these are more operating budget
questions obviously than than Capital to
an extent and um do you know who some of
the big players in this space are yes um
carpel they operate prosecuted by carpel
we've been looking into that um also uh
e prosecutor we've been looking into um
that um that piece of software as well
um there are also some newer Salesforce
based um applications that we've been
looking at as well sort of my question
yeah yes um just everybody around the
state is looking at at some version of a
case management system and and
Salesforce we're investing enormous
amounts of money and yeah and I presume
you're working with doit yes most of
your operating costs are are uh related
to this are essentially transfers to do
they're not external operating costs um
we do have some external operating costs
and that we we have again we have a
contractor that we pay for support um
but that's the only external cost okay
that's good to know um yes and the you
said that if the new system has greater
functionality which should almost
certainly will right cuz it 20 years on
it better um there are certain things
you're going to get rid of um or can
replace or or do within the system
instead of having a standalone yes are
there significant savings associated
with that or are they the minimas yes um
Park um Kathy do you pi r I think we
Pace between 600 well we're going up to
$600 to $700,000 a year in a for a
software called everlaw which is an
ecovery management tool I I don't it
will depend on the functionality of our
new system as to whether we could
eliminate all of that cost we may still
need to use everlaw for for certain
cases but that's that's a significant
annual cost that should at least be I
think reduced because prol law just
doesn't have anywhere near the same
functionality as as ever law that was my
question
good Sher good morning um my question to
two questions one is does Microsoft
itself have an alternative product that
they're talking directly with you as a
replacement to prolog no um Microsoft
doesn't operate any case management
software to the extent of my knowledge
um and then the other question is um
what's the project timeline if this was
to move forward like how long would it
take to you know if this is if prola has
the potential of running into issues in
you know 25 with say fiscal 25 um
between an RFP and a bid and contract
and then the actual implementation
what's your overall timeline that you
you would need so typically for a case
management system um shift
um it would be anywhere between three
and five years we're shooting for five
just to be entirely realistic um ideally
we would like to get this up and running
sooner but um currently 5 years is the
timeline and and just to clarify the
one-year piece um and David you can
correct me but when he said we could
lose functionality within a year there
are short-term fixes that can Bridge us
I think the point is just that in as
short of a time as a year we're going to
have to start you know doing some I mean
Patchwork for for lack of a better term
to get us to a new case management
system but it does not mean we will not
be able to function and still you know
function at a high level but uh yeah so
shortterm fixes probably begin within a
year we can get to five years though
that tape will be okay for a few years
so um so if I understand
correctly um you know the maintenance
costs for prw is about 400,000 a year
that is correct and then your storage
your cloud storage costs are about
225,000 a year yes so annually you're
anticipating spending about 625,000 a
year no the so the projected cost for
storage so with the $400,000 figure uh
that is what we currently pay for a
current case management system and that
includes the server the servers that we
have at doit um with a new case
management system we would have to pay
for for maintenance for um for licenses
and all that um but in addition to that
we'd have to pay for the cloud storage
um in doing so we' wouldd be getting rid
of the servers at doit so we would no
longer have to pay for those servers but
we would now have to pay for cloud
storage space um which again the high
end is $223,000 a year but uh if we uh
archive a data that we no longer need
than it that could drop drastically
understood so you're paying for cloud
storage with the new system right yes
and you're paying 400,000 a year
approximately for the new system um so
that the
$400,000 figure U that would include the
cloud storage as well so in addition in
addition to maintenance and cloud
storage and Licensing fees in total the
package would be in the ballpark of
$400,000 a year yeah based on your
I guess I don't understand what the
slide yeah um so the 223,000 would be
what we would pay specifically just for
the cloud storage right once we move the
the server from theit's basement onto
let's say the Amazon government Cloud
that's what we would be paying for that
and you know um we'd be paying let's say
$223,000 a year for uh Cloud space and
then maybe another 50,000 for licenses
another 50,000 for maintenance and it's
part of the 400k yeah which I can see
why that might have been a little conf
yeah I I apologize uh what do you expect
the useful life of the system is I mean
you use prol for 20 years what's the
useful life of this system so um
we based off of you know the fact that
PR law has has more or less worked for
us for the last 20 soon be probably
around 25 years by the time we replace
it we expect this system to also um to
last us hopefully just as long obviously
we can't tell the future we don't know
if there's going to be any kind of um
hiccups along the way but if we go with
a newer system then we are more likely
to see a more longevity out of uh the
system as well obviously if we go with a
with a case management system that's 10
years old already it may only last US 10
to 15 years um so um we have to use our
judgment in that case and and go with
something that we we believe will last
us longer ideally it lasts us as as long
as possible um but based off of pre
precedence I want to say 20
years and uh and then you mentioned that
you had a a
fiveyear implementation plan do you
expect to U come back in a
future uh capital budget cycle and ask
for more money for this system so for
for this specific system or for current
system so um for for this specific
system we we intend for this to be the
end all be all um So within that time
between now and let's say in 5 years
when the system gets implemented um we
may lose functionality with our current
uh case management system um which we're
going to do our best to try and find
some kind of way to keep it chugging
along but in terms of this specific new
case management system 2.2 million is
the endol be all thank you yes
any other
questions thank you very much thank you
thank
you like to invite the uh Department of
good
morning hi good morning committee
members good morning my name is Tammy
Valen cour I'm the Chief Financial
Officer for the Department of Education
and with me I have Jeff beard he's the
administrator for the Perkins Grant and
the CTE
centers
um thank you for allowing me to come
before you and present the Department's
project
projects a summary of the projects that
I will be reviewing is found on page 222
221 of your packet and this year the
only projects we are submitting are for
the Career and Technical Education
Centers um the projects before you are
conal applied Technology Center this is
a $14.7 million
renovation um to include demolishing
rebuilding and adding to the existing
structure
this will allow the reconfiguration of
program offerings the addition of new
CTE labs and to launch a new animal
science
program the next project is the msic
auto CTE renovation they're requesting
$1.5 million for minor Renovations and
to build an addition for new Automotive
Bays to allow programming focused on
diesel and electric vehicles as well as
um the Jaffrey ringe CTE renovation they
are requesting $19.4 million for new
construction of a 30,000 sqt addition
this will allow expansion of the
existing construction trade programs as
well as adding cosmetology culinary arts
fire EMT and security and public safety
programs and finally we have the Milford
apply Technology Center renovation this
is a $28.2 million project it's for
Demolition and construction of a new CTE
space to create new labs and add
automotive and Health occupation
programming while the schools have
submitted projects to the department
only one has had a vote at the local
level that did fail but there is
expectations that all projects will be
go up for vote this coming year given
that CTE centers in the state supports
thousands of students focused on Career
and Technical Fields commissioner edbl
Department staff have communicated with
all centers requesting they sharpen
their P pencils to cost effective and to
work together and with the local
community colleges to ensure we are
offering a broad range of educational
opportunities and not duplicating those
opportunities within the same small
geographical area um Jeff is here if you
have specific questions relative to
these projects and that is our
presentation great thank you uh I would
just wonder if you could uh you have
them prioritized in in a certain order I
was wondering if you what your
methodology was in prioritizing them
that way so we prioritize them based on
when they were funded originally and
they just come up on it's like a 20year
schedule and uh just just to add to that
the uh the renovation queue was
established in uh Department of
Education administrative rules that uh
directs us to bring them uh in the order
of priority in which they're listed in
uh table that's in those admin
rules okay thank
you I I wonder if you um um I know this
is an ongoing thing and it it Dawns on
me that um my understanding is that in
in January we're going to have a new
governor who will likely
be have some degree of familiarity or
not with the fact that there's a cue the
fact that we've been doing this for 20
years that there's a there's a schedule
and I I wonder if it would wouldn't be
helpful for capital budget purposes if
you if you could do um just sort of a
cheat sheet for the for the committee
and and for the particularly for James
to lead for his successor unless we can
talk him into staying um just a what
we've done when and over the last pick a
pick a number 12 years 15 years 20 years
whatever you think it makees sense we do
have that schedule and we can provide it
to you I think it would I think it would
make a difference and because when you
sit down yeah you know cuz I'm guessing
that not every politician on the planet
has the CTE schedule as like first and
foremost in the back of their head yeah
that's mych it lists out the schools the
year of the renovation the dollar amount
that was spent back during that time
frame and we can provide send that out
that'll be great otherwise we have to
cler Tammy you mentioned that these um
all need local level approvals and you
said one was presented but had failed
and I was just wondering which one that
would be the Milford one oh Milford okay
and then they would go back to at the
Town level like like next march is that
do all these fall in our March Town time
you okay thank you very much thank you
thank
you like to call up now the community
college system of New
good morning good
morning good morning and thank you for
your time U out of consideration uh for
the U other presentations that will
follow I propose not to walk through a
dozen slides but to just summarize what
I can and then answer questions that you
might have thank
you you're welcome
commissioner uh community college system
of New Hampshire seven colleges 11
physical locations around the state
serving about 23,000 students programs
from Advanced manufacturing to welding
nothing with a z yet but thinking about
it more than 100 programs in between
heavy concentration in healthc care
including a programs set programs that
prepared 320 nurses for New Hampshire
this year two key themes that describe
our work affordability through
partnership with the state to keep
tuition low and
accessibility helping students both
young and working adults to have access
to programs that allow them to uh
support themselves and their families
contribute to New Hampshire's uh
future growing portion of our work is
occurring online but for any number of
our programs again manufacturing related
Automotive Health Care clinical students
need hands-on experience and so the
physical plant that we have across the
St the state is incredibly important to
our work about 35 buildings about 1.6
million square fet uh 2third of those
buildings 40 years old in fact more than
half of them more than 50 years old and
and some showing their their age um as
you'll see from our request what we're
focused on is primarily critical
maintenance uh Energy Management there
are two areas of focus that I'll come
back to but in essence what we're trying
to do is continue to be good stewards of
the physical plant that we have that
serves our state and our
community as our work has increasingly
uh seen a growth in the online side some
of our buildings are larger than we need
uh but we have been able to repurpose uh
nashille is currently working to
introduce a Head Start program as we
have at Manchester and Littleton uh
child care facilities in partnership
with uh with others at um one being
introduced in Berlin one we already have
here in conquered in nhti so want to
make sure that we continue to Steward
these resources not only for our own
programs but for partners in the state
who have use of those facilities in our
communities in this by am requesting 7
half million heavily concentrated on
critical maintenance you'll see on the
last slide an outline of what those
projects are as well as energy
management some of that is actual Energy
Management some of that's also ability
to ensure that we're able to monitor
these systems to optimize them to
anticipate uh imminent failure to
maintain them in a way that lessens the
likelihood of of critical failures that
become more costly to resolve the two
targeted requests that we we've made one
programmatic a continuation of previous
support for Aviation related programs at
Nashua an area of growth and opportunity
critical for the infrastructure for
transportation that also ties to any
number of other Industries served by it
the other one for information technology
not only in support of our growing
online and the need to manage that
environment address cyber security
concerns but also to more fully assess
what the future our enterprise system
system is we have been on enterprise
system supporting our student facing
services for almost two decades it
happen to be the same system that the
university system has been on you may
have noted that in the governor's task
force this past spring one of the
recommendations that we look to move to
an enterprise system that would align
with University Systems so part of this
is to continue the assessment to
optimize what we have but assess whether
there's a possibility of moving to A A A
system okay um yeah couple of of of
questions mainly the first one is your
deferred maintenance uh do you have a a
total amount of deferred maintenance
that that you're dealing with that that
you have in the back of your head as far
as what it would take and I know
commissioner alling house does for the
state but I I I'm I'm look looking to a
colleague in the past we've used around
number of 70 million I'm going to ask
the Chief Operating Officer Scott Fields
that good
morning the number that the chancellor
has put out is is correct what we do is
on an annualized basis we target to kind
of match what our depreciation level is
on an annual basis which is roughly 7 a.
half million dollar um that we spend to
maintain our
colleges okay and where does most of
that money come from other than
sometimes you get through the capital
budget but it was roughly two-thirds of
that comes from uh College operations
College operations with a third of it
coming from the state this has become a
focus for our board to elevate the
amount of Investments that's being made
in oper uh plant maintenance to ensure
the Integrity of these buildings okay
you you've done um some work with uh um
I asked uh um I asked the other
Chancellor um a question about housing
and and uh old buildings and um first of
all let me give you credit for your for
your slides um that you have one of my
favorite Winston Churchill quotes on the
front so I certainly appreciate that um
the uh uh do you look at um excess
capacity and I I happen to drive by the
Tech every day and I and I I feel like
something's going on there we we we we
do
and housing is a critical need and
housing in security is a critical need
for many students in community colleges
nhti is unique among our colleges in
that it has three facilities that have
capacity for about 330
students post pandemic the demand had
fallen off and so for the last year
there's been lease arrangement with a
private entity that makes use of that
for educational purposes compliment to
what we do but not not quite the same uh
o over time we're continuing to look at
all of our physical plant to figure out
if it's best highest use as I mentioned
earlier the child care centers the Head
Start spaces that are available in some
cases we've had uh colleagues of state
agencies Health and Human Services part
of employment supports making use of
office space because the clients they
serve often have need for programs that
we offer so we're looking always for
complimentary uses for available space
um for Partnerships that have synergies
that that may be mutually beneficial not
just to the community college system but
to other organizations or
you so I just had one um more general
question which is among these four
categories your energy critical
maintenance Etc um is the funding or the
projects scalable within each of those
so because it looks like there's um you
know under for example under critical
maintenance might be multiple buildings
that are happening so if that instead of
7.8 if something was I'm going to make
out numbers but 5.8 you know is that
scalable in terms of what then you could
prioritize within it is every set of
projects there's a prioritized list of
critical need and so if if it's less but
like if it's more we we can also
accommodate you would find other things
the the the the buildings and and as
somebody of the same vintage buildings
in their 60s and approaching 70 years
still have useful life but some of the
update so I noticed in your critical
maintenance slide um you have a total of
66 projects and your ask is $7.8 million
and do you think you could accomplish
all 66 projects for the 7.8 million
absolutely the the 66 projects that you
see the way that as the chancellor
mentioned we have a list of prioritized
items a project of the 66 could be just
a hand an air handler an hhc unit uh not
to the same scale as with the university
system presented earlier it's not on
that wide scale there being able to
maintain individual units as they go
across the the different locations
you okay great thank you very much
you i' like to invite up now please the
good morning good morning director Jerry
members of the committee I'm Paul Breen
for the record with peace Development
Authority the executive director I'm Jo
joined with acting Port director from
division and ports and harbors miles
Greenway and our finance director at
peas Development Authority Suzanne
anzalone um just for a quick history uh
peas had legislature merged division of
ports of harbers with the peace
Development Authority in 2001 and peace
Authority provides administrative
oversight for division in ports and
harbors uh peas itself is self-funding
our Capital Improvement program um we
are specifically here for the division
of ports and harbors and they have two
prioritizing items that director
Greenway will will uh happy to answer
any questions on the
package hi good morning uh miles
Greenway so the first one is for Ry
Harbor and Hampton Harbor rip W repair
uh sorry apologies no slide deck but
what I do have is severe storm impact uh
document that we have so basically uh
this is to hold what we have for
property is the way I look at it as well
so if we take a look at
page uh 12 and 13 uh pictures tell a
thousand words of what we had for Ry
Harbor coming through that area in
January two different storms within a
one week time frame uh what we aren't
seeing we do see the white water but uh
these are this is a video actually and
these are just snapshots of that video
with the rip wrap repair what we're
hoping to get right there we know the
water isn't going to stop coming in but
we don't will stop that flow coming
in for damages that we had during that
uh our fuel system and our ramp system
were damages and that is on page
nine and on page six and seven we had
from that as
well uh and that as a reminder of those
of you that if don't know that we did
just rece receive a million dollars in
arpa funding uh for additional work down
well and specifically that Opera funding
is for economic development for the
retail uh Goods down there Ry Harbor
does support uh commercial fishing
commercial lobstering um and numerous
tourists such as uh wheel watch and
charter fishing as well as um retail
and to add for fuel not just uh in
Portsmouth but in Rye and Hampton as
well uh fuel's important not just for
the commercial fishermen and
recreational us users it is uh state law
enforcement local law enforcement and
federal law law enforcement with the co
well the second uh project that we have
is for the um Market Street marine
terminal
so this is for dredging in front of the
in front of the terminal so um within
that package there is a a picture of it
but so the federal channel is at
maintained by the Army Corps of engineer
at 35 ft uh we have 35 ft on the south
end of the dock but we're up Shing up to
30 and 32 on the Northern side of the
dock which is by the song Bridge so the
Street terminal is the only deep water
port in the state of New Hampshire it uh
serves as an ad hoc bulk distribution
facility uh primarily all of New
Hampshire's roadway salt um comes
through the facility it's a critical
piece into other uh utility
infrastructure programs throughout the
state uh for instance uh utility
entities will use it for large scale uh
direct shipments from from Europe and
and South America uh uh for for any type
of power station or antrum wind farm
that type of work um that that is goes
to Market Street currently we we
advertise
3,500 um meters of depth and we're we're
we're only at 3200 without this dredge
so we've recently completed a project um
with your help to restore the pair to a
good State of Affair it's in great shape
now um this dredge would help us uh win
some of the business in the region for
those ad hoc large scale
shipments in addition the vessels right
now currently when we get salt ships
they lighter in Boston and then when
they more they immediately start
discharging from the number one and
number two holds to what lighter the
ship more because of the
Shing
okay that's all I have sir okay great uh
I just wonder if you could uh
tell us about your your Capital needs
going forward obviously for building
repairs those happen sporadically maybe
once every 20 years but but dredging
which is a topic I know very little
about uh is a continuous thing it would
seem and if you could just uh expand
upon that like what what what's the need
for dredging going forward and on in
your different ports number one and
number two what other uh significant
Capital needs does support does the
Development Authority
uh believe they might have going forward
in the next 5 to 10 years or any large
ticket items yes sir so for the drudging
uh that we're requesting right now I'd
have to we'd have to actually do it the
dredging itself and then continue with
surveys with the Army Corps or a loc
local surveying team that we hire
because it's not part of the federal
Channel I I know it does say there's a a
year in SMA let useful life but I think
that might have been left over where we
just have to wait and see I mean just
recently the Army Corps went up to the
reach and had to do maintenance dredging
as well so there could be a chance that
in the next 2 to 3 years we'd have to
maintenance dredges again but I we'd
have to wait and see with that as well
so for the other drudging that we also
are uh doing is a 107 feasibility uh as
a state rep and that's down in Hampton
seab Brook and that's moving forward
with the Army Corps doing that that's a
nav safety uh analysis to see how that's
going to um impact the Waterway uh to
include the new 1A Bridge after that as
well okay thank you and director Jerry
one more priority uh that we do foresee
in the next uh two two to three years uh
we do not understand what you're all up
against we do not put it into this uh
package but uh the Market Street
Terminal Warehouse in Portsmouth which
uh was originally designed for liquor
distribution before uh the state uh
amended the way that it it handles its
uh liquor sales um that warehouse is at
end of life um anybody that crosses the
the bridge in Dom main we'll probably
see The Rusted route uh roof on that on
that building um we do are looking to to
keep the core office space that supports
Division and ports and harbor us uh
Customs um and and other entities that
that utilize the facility but uh we do
anticipate about a 3 to 5 million
Capital expense down the road uh to
you any other
questions I think we're good thank you
you hey next up the list is Parks uh
dncr Department of Natural and cultural
up it's uh it's like that thing in
po good
morning good
morning I brought my a
team um and I'll introduce as we go
along my name is Sarah Stewart I serve
as the commissioner of the New Hampshire
Department of Natural and cultural
resources um so I'm going to provide
just a brief overview remarks and then
we'll list off our 11 priorities and
we'll take questions
based on where you want to um dig in so
I'll start by saying it's an honor to
speak with you this morning to present
the Department of Natural and cultural
resources capital budget request for the
2627 biennium uh this department is made
up of the division of Parks and
Recreation the division of forest and
lands the division of historical
resources the New Hampshire State
library and the New Hampshire State
Council on the Arts uh New Hampshire is
the state that is known for its natural
Beauty Amazing Outdoor Recreation
vibrant cultural activity and our
commitment to honoring our past these
are the natural and cultural resources
we are proud to prot protect promote
manage and it's with your support that
we can create the best experiences for
our citizens and our
visitors so our department cares for 884
buildings 22 Bridges 26 dams 147 septic
systems
1,427 camp sites a fleet of 298 vehicles
and many collections that are uh include
many collections which include rare
Irreplaceable and valuable items these
valuable items are primarily stored at
the New Hampshire State Library building
but are also tucked within various other
locations around the state like at our
headquarters State Park and State Forest
offices and our historic
sites so thanks to the support of um our
Administration and the legislature over
the years we've made much progress
tackling deferred maintenance but we
still have more to do and we must
acknowledge the millions of arpa dollars
allocated to this agency we have been
able to purchase brand new snowmobile
trail groomers develop plans for
campsite expansion uh replace very old
and outdated bathroom facilities tackle
safety and deferred maintenance at some
of our beloved historic sites and with
the assistance from DPW we continue to
plug away at these ARA projects in order
to hit our
deadlines we have prepared for you a
$37.5 million Capital Improvement
project request for the next
bium and to put this in perspective this
is about what uh Jason Tatum makes in a
year which I thought was fitting on a
Day of Victory like today just to get
you smiling
Charlie go
Celtics so I'm going to read off our 11
priorities and then we can dig in um to
to details so in order uh our number one
priority this year is um securing the
funding to complete a new Tramway in
Frank francon Notch State Park our
second priority is uh funding to uh
design a State Library facility that is
offsite um over by our archives
building we then have uh facilities in
our forest and lands division that need
attention number four is Roofing and
repairs and which is something that we
always um include in our
priorities um we have roads and parking
lots we have toilet building
upgrades uh we have The Lodges at Canon
Mountain which need some
attention uh historic sites restoration
SE Coast planning and resilience
similarly to what you just heard from
the Port Authority um amog State Park
Marina and facilities and finally uh the
Connecticut Headwater Road repair
project um with that I think I will
pause I brought with me to the table
this morning Brian Wilson who is our
state parks director and our State
library in Michael York um because those
are the two projects at the top which
are are my
bium okay uh question uh on the Tramway
there was was it approximately 17
million 18 million that was uh
appropriated by the legislature in the
last budget and now this uh is an
additional ask on top of that to meet
the $33 million bid correct so we um we
went to the legislative um bodies and
requested 25 million um through a a
really lengthy and thoughtful process uh
we were happy to accept the 18 million
um knowing that we could could fill a
gap uh to that 25 with a variety of
other potential funding opportunities uh
we went out to bid um and uh we received
one bid and that was 33 we have sort of
stepped you know gone back to our
Corners reconsidered how we want to uh
approach this um and we have a plan in
place uh in coordination with DPW um and
some engineering experts to go back out
to bid um
and and our goal is to separate out the
um the Val validated health and security
of our existing concrete Towers which
should help reduce the overall cost uh
that wasn't clear in our first bidding
process so we learned that lesson um but
in order to go back out to bid we I
think we need to have the 33 available
um and that's what we're asking for to
get us there in in the governor's uh
statement he mentioned needs vers things
that are nice to have why is the tram a
need versus something that's I'll go
first and then I'll let Brian jump in um
it's it's definitely a revenue uh need
for our Park system which is
operationally self-funded uh generates
uh significant Revenue that we then um
spread around the park system or help
support the entire park system which is
uh very closely integrated um several
years ago the state invested in the
Hampton Beach SE seashell building for
several million dollars it was a big
deal uh a big deal for the community and
um when we were testifying in you know
in in in our initial request for funding
for the tram the head of the Hampton
Beach Chamber of Commerce came and said
you all did this for our region and the
state which which dramatically uh
boosted our local economy uh I'm here to
support you making a similar investment
in another part of the state which I
thought was um a great perspective um in
addition to own Revenue having the tram
in uh in the notch is a huge draw for
tourism and um and we have the support
of uh the the local Chambers up there as
well for uh making sure that um that
this investment that the state has made
uh twice before um is realized so that
they uh can continue to benefit from
from the activity there and how much
revenue does it does it bring in
annually uh the tram itself um generates
uh about 1.6 to$ 1.8 million annually
yeah any guesses on what what the total
impact of the tram is I mean because
obviously when people come and see the
tram they're just spending time uh up in
that area and going to restaurants and
shops and things like that and doing
other things sure well um we we haven't
done any uh economic analysis
specifically to to the tram but other
comparative data uh that like the travel
and tourism does for instance um have
have shown that for every dollar
invested in outdoor recreation generates
$25 in tax revenue so uh you think of
you know people using the roads or
visiting restaurants uh and and those
things um I could say that frankon not
State Park as our Flagship State Park in
in the park system uh is is bringing
people from all over the world uh
regularly to New Hampshire uh on a yearr
round basis um so not unlike Hampton
Beach uh the in investment that goes
back into the park system not only helps
uh support our operationally selfs
supported uh Park system we need the
infrastructure to be able to just do the
day-to-day stuff and and and welcome
people to our locations um but um that
it goes beyond just the revenue directly
uh injected into our our operations um
and and really supports the community
right large in a big way okay and and
finally for me um how old is the current
tram and this new tram does it have a
similar expected life uh the current
tram is 44 years old um we on tram
version two two uh the first tram uh was
40 years old when that was uh um
replaced with the current tram in 1980
um and we have been given a very hard
stop of uh of next summer uh from the
current manufacturer of of the current
operation so uh it is critical uh both
for uh kind of the livelihood of the
Canon mountain and frankon Notch but
really the the way that the park system
is is structured that uh if any of our
infrastructure within the park system
goes down for instance our largest
Campground in the park system right now
Greenfield state park is closed for the
entire year uh so that we can catch up
on deferred maintenance there um that
has you know a half a million dollar
operational impact to us
um but I can only imagine the economic
impact to the greater Greenfield
Community um by not having thousands uh
tens of thousands of of campers coming
coming to visit so uh it's it's it's
kind of a it's it's it's a critical
feature within the state park system of
the importance of our infrastructure
okay I said it would be the last
question I I lied to you um one one more
the
um when when the system uh is the new
system is is built and put in place how
long will the will the TR be down for
maintenance when you do that so you're
going to lose a summer basically in my
guess we we had um uh on our last
iteration of it we were we were planning
for about a year and a half so we were
going to lose an entire summer and
probably one winter operation for for
the construction period I don't see that
changing really although we as the
commissioner said we've kind of gone
back to our Corners to re-evaluate
different approaches to this um the
complexity of that project would will
probably take uh a good 12 to 18 months
thank
you um I know we we talk a lot about the
park system being self-supporting and um
which is which is uh different from a
lot of places around the country um it's
not the case that every Park is
self-supporting it's naturally the case
that some parks make a great deal of
money and some parks make you know the
way Parks exist right they don't make a
great deal of money uh frankonia makes
the most money of the system maybe
Hampton how much um oh boy uh well Park
um I I think uh frankon Notch is is
generating over4 million of Revenue and
that's outside that's not including the
Canon the ski operation which is another
9 million so combined $13 million in in
in Revenue produced through frankon not
on on an annual period so that is
definitely the number one
um really the summer drivers for at
frankon Notch are are The Flume which is
about a little over $3 million in
Revenue um and then the tram is kind of
the second largest attraction during the
summertime with the $1.8 million in
Revenue so some level the investment
you're asking for is not an investment
just in one giant metal box but in the
park
system yes yes and I I would argue that
that same logic should be applied to
generally everything that we're asking
for you know whe whether it's roads or
uh updated Utility Systems we can't
operate campgrounds if we don't have a
safe way to get people in and out of in
and out of a campground or if we don't
have if we're not able to keep the
lights on because our uh utility
infrastructure is 60 years old um and
we've got to close places down because
of that then uh yes the infrastructure
investment is critical no I I get that I
was looking in in in a colleague's
office today and amazed at the complete
lack of outlets that she has and it's Cu
uh because it's 85 years old in that
particular case um I don't want to not
talk about the State library because
it's one of my favorite things and um
but I want to chastise if I can the
commissioner for letting Michael York
retire that doesn't seem appropriate is
there was there no way you could stop
that from
happening I'm
old I uh
we're all old we we have been so lucky
to have um Michael as the head of our
State library for a number of years um
and he has really been pushing for the
future of the State Library um and um
you know the the the research we've done
we you know we we've contracted with a
firm to give us a really good blueprint
to move forward um but if if Michael
hadn't been
um banging on the the the gavel for
years um we might not be where we are
today which is at a perfect point to um
to save our Collections and to um free
up some space in the the beautiful State
Library building so that we can really
engage with the public as we we want to
to fulfill our mission I I will say that
um the last time we transitioned from
one Governor to another um I had the uh
fortune or Misfortune depending on your
perspective to help out um the guy
coming in and my friend Jamie brunett
and I um who was doing something with
the transition to had had his meeting
with the acting Commissioner of cultural
resources at the time uh next to an
office that has had a leak in it that I
think still has a leak in it probably
we'll ask Karen about that later but um
and it was our favorite meeting of the
entire transition I will say that uh not
just because there was a raging
snowstorm but um uh you're losing a very
good valuable state employee but um this
particular project um but we wish you
well in your retirement it's a good
thing um this particular project
um storage uh building near the archives
can you talk a little bit about the and
you know there's the history between the
library and the archives and the but I
think we all get along better than than
maybe we did 50 years ago um can you
talk a little bit about that and and
sort of the the the way in which this
will not just preserve the um the
documents and the and the and the rare
volumes Etc but will also enhance the
the building itself um for future
uses well again I think the most
important thing is to protect the
valuable materials that we have in the
State Library uh we are the oldest
institution of our type in the country
nobody else comes close and this was
validated as a question on Jeopardy in
2017 by the way um so we have been
collecting since
1717 and we have a number of incredibly
valuable things and the building is just
not capable of
providing um climate control and the
security that we think is necessary the
process that we've
um chosen to to use is to Simply move
those valuable materials to a purpose
built facility which will be climate
controlled which will be secure because
there's very little that we can do with
the existing building I think it's
important to remember
that uh the building at 20 Park Street
was built um in in uh 1896 to house both
the uh uh Supreme Court and the State
library and then when we ran out of
space or uh were tight for space in the
mid-30s they put
in um mezzanines which were very
functional but horrible they destroyed
the character of the building if you
look in our lobby we have the ASB built
sketches uh from 1896 and you can see
that it's just a spectacular building
with the Rotunda for the the Rotunda
room for the Supreme Court but then also
just a beautiful reading room which
looks very much like the reading room at
the Boston Public Library so um this I
think will give us the opportunity first
of all to protect the materials that we
need to do we have a very
small uh room that we constructed about
15 years ago to take our some of our
valuable materials but not anywhere near
what we need to protect um but in in in
a in addition to that we will free up
space um as the commissioner has said on
more than one occasion to make this a
more public facing building it people
always remark on how beautiful the
building is it's built with New
Hampshire Granite uh Bethlehem
Steel and uh Mosaic uh floors done by
Italian Craftsman so there's a real
opportunity to have this as a a
centerpiece not to take anything from
the state house we don't don't want to
upstage the state house but it's a
beautiful building that we really should
show off and more importantly to me as a
librarian we need to do a better job of
protecting our materials so um it's it's
time to do this we think that this is a
good plan it's not that much money it's
only a third of what tum makes right
so so I think this this is the time and
I greatly appreciate your kind words
I've always enjoyed speaking to both you
and to Jamie Bernett uh we're both wild
cats so I've been talking to him for a
long time it's a very good thing I'm a
little disappointed that you're not
wearing your Smithsonian tie is I'm not
sure I've seen you without it oh is it
in your pocket oh there we go that's
very good I didn't get a chance to put
it on this morning congrat ulations and
thank you for your service thank you
words thank you very much appreciate
all and up next Department of
good morning hi um I'm sorry the
commissioner had to leave I um
um so uh I'm Charlie Arling housee I'm
the commissioner of administrative
services and you are I'm Karen rcky the
director of plant property
um so Karen is an engineer and in charge
of buildings so all the tough questions
will go to her um I'm here mostly for
fluff um I want to I want to talk about
I don't want to go through specifically
every request we have in our budget the
administrative Services part of the
capital budget is usually usually
lengthy and not terribly exciting and
which is a a description of our
department on some level um we do all
the things that aren't terribly exciting
but are critically important we manage
something like 91 state buildings um
there's probably 4 million square feet
of office space in the city of conquered
alone that we take care of um we have
deferred maintenance um that's not
accurate and we have so much deferred
maintenance that that we don't keep an
accurate number but a good ball Park
estimate of how much deferred
maintenance is probably about a billion
dollars um I could I could probably get
to a billion and a half if you wanted me
to um and obviously we're not going to
do that kind of we're not going to do
that kind of stuff so we're not going to
um um keep that accurate a list um um
basically what we do is we take care of
state buildings we take care of a lot of
state buildings and we take care of them
as best we can there are every
maintenance and utility discussion
you've had here today so far applies to
us as well um I want to talk about how
how we come up with the numbers that we
present to you um how do how do we
Whittle down the things that need to
happen the things that want to happen
let me talk separately about the
judicial
branch and the rest of us so to speak
executive and legislative branch because
we we do also take care of the State
House and the
L I don't know if I want to bring up the
L cuz we're meeting here cuz the HVAC
system is down so so read into that what
you will that's either really good
timing or really bad timing
um we look at uh so the judicial branch
though there are cour houses all over
the state we lease space and we and we
own space we build courthouses and we
lease cour houses that process is done a
little bit differently there's a court
accreditation committee that talks about
standards there's a committee with um
actually all of the all of the operating
Chiefs of the the Chief Justice and and
the ad administrative judge of the the
circuit court and Superior Court and and
we go through all of the projects one by
one by one the state tends to build a
courthouse every capital budget maybe
not every single capital budget um six
years ago we built three I want to say
we did Hampton Milford and March County
in the same year does that sound right
oh good she's nodding
um uh we're currently in the process of
building a new courthouse in Rochester
uh you'll see cour houses on this list
and and what happens is the the court
system will prioritize based on how good
or bad they are you'll see um discussion
about Sullivan County the state has
needs in Sullivan County like like uh
the rest of the the state represented
cler will know that those are not
necessarily the premier cour houses in
the system although they're in lovely
spots on a Newport is quite nice Don
clont is quite nice but they need work
those priorities are set through the
court of process that includes
legislative input uh public members
appointed by um by the governor um I
tend to be lawyers and and in one case a
construction executive um the executive
branch needs we go through Caren staff
basically um walks all of the buildings
uh once every couple of years a process
that happened probably a good six months
ago and looks at the needs and we
identify the most pressing needs when I
when I started as commissioner which is
about 7 years ago I had a meeting one
day with uh Karen's predecessor Steve
laurenson actually um and I think Karen
was in the meeting too as Deputy at the
time and um he started talking to me
about leaks leaky roofs and this I've
talked about this before um a 12 bucket
leak and a six bucket leak and and you
know I I I figure this is like a
technical engineering term right that
you know a bucket or it's like a jewel
or a watt or you know pick something and
I said can you explain what that means
and he said sure like in Dairy um when
it rains there are six spots that we put
buckets to catch the
drips that's a six bucket leak if
there's nine it's a nine bucket leak and
I went oh okay I kind of get that uh we
tend to ask for money to fix the 12
bucket leaks and there's not usually
enough money to fix the six we we have a
lot on here along those lines we also
like to pursue projects we're in the
process of trying to renew as best we
can State space the State House Annex
for example is 85 years
old um the fact that so little work had
been done to it except the third floor
there was a fire 50 years ago we did
some work when after the fire but um
we're in the process of of doing phase
one of the renovations so if you go over
there if you go to the GNC breakfast um
in a week um in the middle of a
construction zone it should be um
instructive um but we're doing that uh
the money for phase two of that project
is is is here and Karen's going to talk
a little bit about that she's not going
to going go through every project but
what I want you to know is is is that
this is not the work that needs to be
done this is a subset of the work that
needs to be done because we you can't
afford to do all the work that needs to
be done I think the general fund total
of the of our department request is like
190 oh 150 I saved you money already um
million dollars and and if you said I
got 400 I there's no no way I couldn't
spend that money and that there's just
and and it wouldn't be like did you
really need to do that it would be it
would be we do leaky roofs we do we do
fire panels to bring um um uh buildings
up to code and we try to renew if you go
through some of the older buildings in
the state system one of the things
you'll find as you walk
around um you'll look walk through them
and say good Lord and the number of
times you say good Lord is is akin to
the number of buckets um but it's it's
that kind of thing where can we just do
this and so what we're our current plan
going forward is to try to do as
somebody moves out of space recently the
van McLoud building um people moved out
of that space and other people moved in
it was dncr people who moved out and it
was dasas people who happen to move in
we took U maintenance money and we did
we did mold remediation we did uh basic
painting Patchwork on walls a little bit
of car carpeting moving to carpet
squares as everybody's doing um because
of the long-term maintenance savings
that come from that and it was modest
makes an enormous difference um and
we're trying to do that everywhere and
there's a little bit of that in the
budget too but I'm going to let Karen
talk to some of those points
now thank you I'm going to cover a
couple things that that Charlie didn't
mention so one of the things that I um
kind of keep track of is you know the
industry standard for investing in your
buildings is 2% of your building value
every year right so over um the course
of 50 years you're kind of you know paid
for your building prce um our portfolio
our 91 buildings I look this up value
probably between 750 million and a
billion dollars total um so that means
that we should be investing at least 15
million or 20 million a year or 30 to 40
million per banum so just to give a
ballpark and I know um you know as Char
mentioned our requests are about 150
million and those are the things that we
think we need to do in the next two to
three years and then there's other
projects that stack up after that um in
addition to you Charlie kind of went
through commissioner alling house went
through the process um that the court uh
the judicial branch goes through to
prioritize their needs we're at Central
facilities which is the rest of our
buildings we're going through a um
facility condition assessment this
coming year um so we were able to fund
that through our maintenance funds as
well and that will give us a really
detailed idea of where our deferred
maintenance is how many years we have
have left on different pieces of
equipment different um pieces of our
infrastructure so we're looking forward
to getting the results of that and
that's going to help inform our next
round of capital
projects um so as Charlie mentioned um
we do have a way that we kind of
prioritize our projects um there's an
emergency fund that's managed through my
office where we have historically have
received you know around $1.5 million um
that's available for any state agency to
tap into should they have an emergency
situ situation that was not planned for
um some of the things that we funded in
the past um are failed HVAC systems or
boilers as you know we can't get through
it winter if you don't have heat so
that's that becomes an emergency and
that needs to get fixed ASAP um water
damage that happens we we have water
damage either from the roof leaks that
commissioner Arling house mentioned or
sometimes if we have an piece of HVAC
equipment fail the water in that system
or the chemicals in that system leak out
and they cause damage to the building so
various things like that become
emergencies if the building becomes
uninhabitable we need to get that fixed
right away and make sure that state
agencies can continue their
operations um kind of next down after
that is our life Safety project so fire
panels came up um fire panels elevators
things that we absolutely need to
operate a building become life safety
issues boilers become Life Safety here
in New Hampshire because of the
temperatures that we're dealing with um
next after that is building preservation
so we don't want to let our buildings
get so bad that then they cost even more
to repair so things like roofs um brick
repointing uh over time that becomes
something that you can't fix and then it
has to be reconstructed new construction
renovation kind of comes after that and
then we have Energy savings and
automation so things that make our
buildings more efficient whether it be
through Energy savings or just labor
savings because of
automation um so so that's kind of my
overview I I do have all of the
information on the projects in front of
me today and I'm happy to answer any
questions the two handouts that came
around one is regarding the phase 2
renovation of the State House Annex so
we're starting that phase one renovation
now there's a couple images here that
just show what the building is going to
look like once it's 100% complete um the
office space is going to be much much
nicer and much more efficient um the
layout is kind of the second picture
that you have there which kind of shows
a combination of open office area space
with some offices sprinkled in there so
that um supervisors can be in the same
area their staff um but the space is
used much more efficiently and then the
final picture is an old picture of what
the annex used to look like from the
outside which shows what we really want
to restore the windows to look like
because the windows on honestly right
now are kind of hideous so um so that's
that first handout you have the second
handout alludes to the Sullivan County
uh request that commissioner Arling
house also mentioned and it has two
pages of photos from each of the cour
houses so Claremont Circuit Court
Sullivan um I'm sorry Newport yeah
Sullivan County and um and and Newport
uh Circuit Court um my superintendent of
Court facilities took some pictures just
to show the deficiencies in those
current locations um to kind of indicate
you know why we're making this request
to consolidate those three cour houses
into one new
facility the thing I forgot to mention
is the the on the prioritize list the
number one request is an IT request
which is related to the the state's
enterprise system um historically uh
Enterprise systems of that nature of the
Statewide nature the enterprise system
being the the computer system that runs
well all of state government it does
payroll HR finances budgeting
purchasing well everything um there are
routine and regular upgrades that that
need to be done to it and and the state
adopted a posture about 10 years ago um
people will know this um if you're um
old like me um that the state for a long
time one of the ways the state decided
to save money was by not uh keeping up
on on its computer system so that um you
save a little bit of money each year and
then you have a catastrophic failure in
I think it was 2006 78 in that range and
you have to spend God awful amounts of
money because everyone who knew how to
maintain the system has either died or
retired let's assume they all retired um
and and you don't want that so this is a
modest request it's about $5 million but
it would going forward we would we would
not just uh we're we're going through an
upgrade right now A M A significant
modernization but we would look at
subsystems that are not part of it you
know treasury might be an example of
that for example for for I don't know
cashbook and other treasury things that
I don't understand that Sherry will
laugh at me if I talk too much about
them um but that's that piece as
well any questions anybody has
whatsoever uh paent okay thank you
because I from Claremont in Sullivan
County and my question is I think the
total request and I'm reading figures a
little bit 28 million for the
renovations to the Sullivan County
courts I mean I'm sorry if I'm reading
that wrong 20 or 20 28 I think I read
that correctly 656 that's that is right
total cost for those courts in Claremont
and Newport correct it would be a single
building that would be constructed that
would incorporate all three of those
current which are all leased locations
currently okay a single building and a
followup how in the priority list is
this going to I mean do you have Rec how
what's the priority for for Sullivan
County whatever work you uh want to do
so this was the number one request from
the judicial branch it falls at number
six in the overall Das list so that's
after the IT project that commissioner
Arling house mentioned in several other
kind of Life Safety projects that we
have okay just to be clear uh thank you
oh you said it's number one in the
judicial branch is that correct yeah so
the so it's the number one priority of
the court system that's what court
system wants but in the overall listing
it's actually just number it's six but
in
our extensive list that's pretty let's
just put that in the upper quintile okay
all right six out of 34 in a list that
goes Way Beyond 34 exactly
okay yeah my my question is you you
mentioned that total uh deferred
maintenance being somewhere a billion
you get up to a billion five but let's
let's let's use the billion because it's
I'm not good at math so we have that we
have request for 150 million for the B
Anum that $75 million a year that's
75% uh of your total lower cost of your
deferred
maintenance is that
enough well I mean the the obvious
answer is no but it it it has to be and
the the the state the state has a has a
method and at the end of the day um I
used to say to people that they they
name new Bridges after people they don't
name Bridge repairs after anybody um and
that's true of the Leaky Roof as well
right that they they don't name this is
the the James Gary Memorial um maybe
won't put Memorial in there um roof
repair um it's it's just a natural thing
that that there are going to be big
projects we're going to see some right
in the course of a day and a half of
hearings we're going to see some really
big items and you look at it and you
say well I'm going to use I'm going to
use uh commissioner steuart as an
example right the the the Tramway is a
really really really big important thing
and and you get that and you get that
because of the size of it and the scope
of it and the and the impact is so much
more dramatic related to it um the ouse
repairs are arguably on a Saturday
afteron noon in in in June equally
important especially to somebody and um
but they're they're they don't have the
have the same cache we're we have a lot
of things like that I mean if if the
state had the money we would probably
want to spend upwards of uh a 100
million a year over the course of about
a dozen years in deferred maintenance so
we had a plan the problem is that's all
bonded all bonded costs and I I don't I
don't see within our financial system
how we get there so what we do is we
look at we just we try to prioritize as
best we can and and and make an effort
and
so is anything ever enough no it's not
and and but it's what we have okay if
you were and this is sort of a a guest
on your part um what I'm I'm trying to
find out is how much are we falling
behind meaning in today's dollars what
what would our referred maintenance look
like 10 years ago uh would it in today's
do would it be a billion you know so
we're maintaining or would it be would
it have been 1.5 billion we actually
made some gains or conversely you we we
despite all the money we're spending are
we still falling behind and and in five
years is that number going to be not 1
billion but 1.3 billion I I think we are
falling further behind and some of that
is related to the to the to the age of
the building it moved some people out
we're we're doing some renovation
particularly mechanical
renovation um to an 85y old building the
annex right that largely constructed in
1939 dedicated I think in 1940 but
um so I moved people out of this you
know decaying building and we moved
three of our divisions um for a brief
period of time which is probably years
not months um to a building that was
built in 1843
on the main building on the State
Hospital campus where where what did we
do we did we did some painting we did
some wiring we did some carpet work and
and it's significantly improved how
improved it's okay and it depends on
what you're trying to do um and you know
the it system is good for this but not
good for that uh the mechanical systems
are are okay but better in some ways
than others so are we falling further
behind we are what's what's the number
the truth is that that we don't know
we've never had to know we've never uh
we've never had a good number this year
um with maintenance fund money Karen
talked about the facility assessment
survey we we're going to for the first
time in decades probably um have a more
comprehensive uh professional facility
assessment it it's going to tell us
things that we don't want to know um
except I would like to know the things I
don't want to know and so well a better
sense of that and you know when are
mechanical systems going to fail you
know I we had an issue with a mechanical
with a air conditioning the other day in
a in a building and I thought in my head
I'm like this is one of the newest
buildings in state government in terms
of Renault and this is one of our newer
mechanical systems and basically what
the tech said is you can't expect a
system that's 20 years old not to break
and I'm like how is it that the system
that I have to expect it's going to
break in my head is the is one of the
least likely to break in the system the
problem is both of those things are true
at the same
time
questions thank you very much thank you
thank
you and with that that concludes our
morning session so we will now be in
p.m.
e
okay good afternoon we're going to
resume the capital budget
hearings for this afternoon and uh first
up is the judicial branch so I'd like to
invite you to come up and give your
good afternoon good afternoon Diane
Martin director of the administrative
office of the courts and Donna Raymond
fiscal manager of the judicial
branch thank you for having us would you
like me to just dive into an overview
all right so I'll give you some
background on why why we are doing this
and how it started um a little bit over
a year ago well more than that I went
out and started touring some courts when
I started in this position and one of my
observations in the courts which I know
other folks have observed is that we
have a lot of paper documents that are
in files that are stored in various
places throughout the courts um those
are actually taking a lot of space that
could be used for other things like
staff um you might see court records you
know in files along the wall like you'd
imagine but you might also see them
under desk spaces wherever we have
courts that are very small wherever they
need to be so um after visiting a few of
those courts I was concerned that we
might be able to make better use of the
space and um make those documents more
easily accessible to members of the
public coming in to get access to them
and so um Julie Lamson our court
operations uh project manager went out
to every single Court in the state and
assessed the stateof court records in
those individual courts and came back to
the administrative Council and reported
that we really need to do something
about the number of paper records in the
courts um and she had a number of
proposals one of which was to start
digitizing the records and we um
implemented that about a year ago by
using just standard um small desktop
scanners and and temporary people um to
come in and start doing that work and
it's actually been fairly effective
however it is incredibly slow and so we
might be doing this um into the next
century and so that might not accomplish
the goal that we had of freeing up that
space and making the records more
accessible so the thought was if we
could get better equipment and some
software we might be able to accomplish
those things more quickly so that really
is what this is for it's for um highe
industrial type scanners and then
software that would allow for
um digitization and accessibility I'm
not a tech person but um to be able to
make those searchable and more easily
retrievable so that is the
concept if you have any questions I'd be
happy to answer them yeah once the
system is online what sort of
Maintenance does it require to keep it
are you going to need this always
because obviously you have new records
coming in every day so most of our
current records are going into our case
management system electronically already
so this is really a historical problem
that hopefully will not be a forever
problem uh it's just something that the
courts haven't had the resources to
commit time to to make it happen so I
think it's onetime expenses are what you
have before you to the extent the
software requires any maintenance that
would be an ongoing expense that is not
included here and would being in the
operating budget okay any estimates on
that and what that would be uh I do have
it I can send it to you I don't know it
off the top of my head very good it's
it's obviously smaller than the the
first uh initial onetime cost okay thank
you any additional questions Mr
commissioner speaking of uh historical
records we we' talked in the past about
um archival storage space in the
basement of the Supreme
Court um which I think Justice Marone
had Champion where is that now um we had
uh in conjunction with your team and the
Bure of Court facilities um an engineer
did a design and an estimate and my
understanding is the estimate was
significantly greater than was hoped and
so I think it was not it was cost
prohibitive at least at this point in
time like 3x right or something like
that it was good yeah so that's so
nothing and there's no capital budget
request related to that anywhere no the
digitization of the the um old books in
the library is ongoing we got Capital
funds and arpa funds for that so that's
occurring I think the Hope was that many
of the artifacts and then the old books
would go into that archive um so I
wouldn't say that Justice Hans Marone
has given up hope but the number that we
you hi Diane hi I I heard you say
accessible and I just want to qualify a
lot of folks are creating PDFs nowadays
and and with the with the new standards
are coming out from the feds uh I just
want to double check that you're
thinking about making sure that the
documents will be accessible according
to federal guidelines so my
understanding is that this would make
them more readily accessible in the
first instance to our court staff so for
example right now if you go to a court
and you need a document let's say the
hearing was in Manchester but the court
houses them in nashaa it may require the
documents to actually be transferred and
so making them accessible to court staff
um and also to make them searchable I'm
not sure about the other requirements
but I can get back to you on that yeah
it what I would suggest that you take a
look and in fact we can share with you
uh Kate Kate mner who's been working on
you know collaborating on website stuff
with your folks um has all kinds of
documentation on that and the way you do
PDFs will determine whether um you know
it's accessible or not whether it falls
into those guidelines and and we're
seeing much more public activity holding
us accountable to doing it correctly so
I'd say doing it up front is going to be
a lot easier and less expensive than you
know having to redo them when after the
fact because somebody calls you out so
that was I just wanted to let you know I
two um my question is more tangental
this morning um Department of Justice
was talking about uh procuring a new
case management system and you had
mentioned that you have one and I was
just wondering if you have been talking
with them at all or what do you use well
so our case management system is more
designed for um court records versus doj
has a very
attorney um their approach and
requirements are very different so we're
certainly always happy to collaborate um
but I think it may be a slightly
different
scope hey see none thank you very much
okay I'd now like
to invite the judicial
councel Mr chairman I think the judicial
Council withdrew their request um you
won't have seen it but this morning oh
please good afternoon is my
understanding that you have withdrawn
your
request okay and and the reason for the
withdrawn request is
microphone the microphone turn it on
just to button in Fr there we go there
we go thank you um we had requested
funding uh through U gopher and we
received some arpa funds and we had also
alongside that issued a request for
information to get a sense of what the
cost would be and we got the some
responses back from the from that
request for information um along with
the Arun and after looking at those two
things it appeared that the ARA funding
was going to be enough to meet our needs
okay very good any do you have any other
Capital needs that you're requesting at
this point no okay easy enough yes first
time I've said this all hearing your
request is
granted thank you you're welcome thank
much uh next on the list is police
you the uh the project that we're
seeking to get uh funding for is to help
increase the physical security of our
building uh
specifically uh to uh be able to build
some doors uh that will help us close
off our lobby uh the building we occupy
was built in the 1980s and there was
really no consideration given uh for
building security back in those
days uh you know clearly uh people can
walk into the building unimpeded right
now it's a it's an open campus much like
a college uh to that end uh we are
seeking funds to allow us to uh put a
door on uh one side of the lobby that
would close off the hallway to the
training uh port of the building and
then a door uh that would close off uh a
ladder well that would access the second
deck where we have uh the conduct Review
Committee and other office space and
residential space on top of that we are
seeking funding that would help us
augment uh a process that would allow us
to have an intercom system and some uh
ACC Access Control to those doors so
that we could have a staff member Buzz
needed okay
uh the the the staff member that would
be buzzing people in and out is that a
new position because you don't obiously
there there are no buzzing and no one
dedicated to that task now so are you
looking for a new position for that as
well someone who maintains the Integrity
of the security or so we we presently do
have somebody who works at at the window
for lack of better term uh are uh we
operate now on the premise that people
are going to be compliant and will uh
actually walk up to the window that's
very deep into the lobby where the staff
member would uh you know address
whatever concerns or questions they have
so we don't need uh an extra person uh
we just need to kind of uh build this um
these safety structures in a way that we
can control that Lobby a little bit
better than we can now okay how many
points of access are there into the
facility
is it just the two or there are there
more that you're not concerned with uh
throughout the entire facility yeah so
uh there are a significant number of
access points uh that will allow people
to enter the building from all portions
of that building uh we were able uh to
um get permission to realign our
existing uh budget we're just getting
rid of to close it out now to help us uh
address a significant number of safety
concerns that we we have to include uh
door access and alarming and uh video
camera so we we were able to kind of
start moving in that direction uh with
all of those other doorways hallways a
lot of common space that we need to to
be able to monitor um this is really
just for that main lobby uh which is
really the the most wide openen portion
of the building okay thank you any other
questions see none thank you very much
folks next up we have the Department of
Services invite you to come up and give
good afternoon good afternoon
commissioner good
request thank you for having us um I
have Dave weers with me uh who's our
chief operating officer who will walk
through um most of the items here today
uh as you can imagine we actually have
quite a bit of capital item requests um
I would like to just point out this is
probably one of the only years that I've
been involved that we've narrowed it
down to eight we usually submit like 15
to 20 some ODS so uh just trying to be
mindful as well um and I'm not sure on
the version that you have um if you have
the kitchen New Hampshire hospital
Kitchen on that yeah so I just wanted to
point out that we have withdrawn that
item um we're looking for alternative
funding for that so that would put these
seven items in front of you today that
through thank you and thank you for um
having me today my my name is David
weeders I'm the chief operating officer
for
thhs and hopefully in your slide deck on
the second um slide you'll see eight
Capital project requests in nine
including the kitchen that would be
stricken or
withdrawn so the first project um
medicated Enterprise modular strategy
I'm going to roll into that into the
third slide here and give you some
background so over the last four or five
years we've been building a Medicaid
enterprise system strategy and we we
leverag Capital funds for the last
couple years to implement um and
actually move forward on provider
Management Systems integrator um data
warehouse Pharmacy benefits management
and electronic visit verifications
modules and then we're we're seeking
additional funds to continue that effort
it is a five-year total project or
program that in order to replace that
system we have up up to about 14 modules
that we're working towards and this next
Capital um request is to continue that
effort and move forward for implementing
the third party liability which is
really maximizing cost of ordance or
addressing fraud in the Medicaid Program
in ensuring that if people have a
commercial insurance or other insurance
that Medicaid is the last the last pay
payer for for those
claims and then the next one is Care
Management or member management it's
really looking to integrate our data
sources and manage our members um very
similar to the new height system or
integrated eligibility but really
building upon that and doing Care
Management across all the Continuum of
Care through services at Health and
Human Service
and then the last module that's
contemplated in this um Capital request
is a call center management so one of
the key components that we're trying to
address is when you go to seek services
and you can see this across the state
but if you go to seek services in DHHS
there's a number of different phone
numbers that you can call if you don't
know which number to call you Call 1800
s DHHS and then they help you get to
another call center and many people
don't necessarily enjoy going from one
call center inter next and going through
call cues our goal is to consolidate
that and look at a department approach
in a whole person or a citizen 360
approach for call center management the
total cost for this one would be
33,700 th000 of which we would be
seeking um Federal funding in the 90%
match and so the general fund impact
would be
$3,375 th000 which you should see in
front of you
today um the key there is we and we are
very optimistic this is following um
center for Medicare and Medicaid
services plans for replacement so we
would be fairly confident of getting
that Federal match
dollars the next one if there wasn't any
questions on the Medicaid enterprise
system I don't know if you want me to
stop um thanks David so you said this
would be about a 5year implementation
have you because it sounded like you
started some of this already so are you
already somewhere in your 5-year period
we are um thank you for the question um
Sherry uh we are basically two years
into the 5-year program so this last two
years we've been doing the system
integrator and laying the foundation for
this
implementation um it's taken some time
to go through rfps and get through
through that so the system integrator
was actually published about three weeks
ago and then we implemented electronic
visit verification module um back in May
or April and May and then we also are on
track with the current capital funding
for the pharmacy benefits management
solution and the um the provider
management and the data warehousing so
those are all funded with existing
Capital this Capital request continues
that and for the next two years of that
b of the next bium and then we'll have a
a subsequent potentially a subsequent
Capital requests for the following bium
to implement the claims module what
What's the total cost you mentioned
you've already been working on this
what's the cost spent to date you have
the 3 uh 3.75 million here and then you
mentioned an additional cost all in
what's What's the total price tag on
this so uh I can give you what we
currently have and I'll try to add it in
my head but the current capital projects
that are in place there's a $90 million
on Capital project for for the mmis or
the medic management information system
reprocurement and then another six
6,700 ,000 I believe 750,000 for the
data the data warehouse so that's 96 750
plus the 33 and I'm not okay I I'll add
it up but and and they're all and the
at yeah and just um yeah the future one
we don't have it planned out because we
would have to go out and do a lot of the
analysis but we I would imagine the
claims engine is going to be anywhere
from 60 to $100 million to do and we're
looking at alternatives to see if we can
avoid that cost in the future and
utilize some of the existing system and
move forward with that but that will
depend on procurement requirements um
Fair Mark Fair um Fair
um Fair access to other vendors as well
as our federal partners and as a
clarification those funds that I was
giving or total costs those are the the
100% all all in 90% of that is federal
dollars
and 10% of it is general fund so that
will be the so if you're looking at 96
plus 33 about 125 million or so 12 a.
half million is the general fund
impact thank you David oh sry you had
said that you were um fairly confident
with the federal reimbursement does that
happen at the very end of the project do
they do approvals along the way at the
90% they do approvals along the way so
it's basically we we file the doents in
in advance we filed our plan our our
total plan of what we're doing including
the claims module they won't actually
approve the dollars until we go and say
this is how much we believe we need for
provider management so what happens is
by the time we go to RFP we've already
have approval to be able to submit the
RFP based off of the not to exceed
amounts if if you're looking at the um
for those of those of us who aren't
computer is um I I'm trying to
understand how this fits into the whole
scheme of government and your operation
and all that so this is about you're
going to spend about 200 million when
you're done is on fair enough it is this
all part of quote unquote
mmis or and now does that just
administer Medicaid um basing that on
its name or how does that fit into your
operation broadly what does it control
service do
so that's a great question commissioner
um it's it's both so the Medicaid
enterprise system the way many states
and our our states know different is
leveraging it is leveraging the Medicaid
funds to replace that Medicaid
management system with infrastructure to
that could be used elsewhere so we're
partnering with um Department of
Information Technology to build some of
those foundations so the system
integrator RFP will will initially be
focused because that's how we get our
funding on Medicaid recipients and
beneficiaries but then it can scale out
to be able to integrate systems for
across DHHS as well as um if the
commissioner goule needs to be a
multi-tenant and use across the the
state um so we're still in those
discussions on how that rolls out but it
is a flexible frame framework so that we
could it's sort of like the phone
company I look at is the system manag
inators like the phone companies where I
can have a Verizon phone you can have a
T-Mobile phone but we all can call each
other um the system integrator allows
for those standards to occur so that you
can call me and not have to switch from
a T-Mobile phone to a Verizon phone to
call me um I don't know if that's a good
analogy but that's that's works for me
EAS um the uh my phone is one of the few
devices I'm capable of using although
you can you'll be able to leverage this
internally for other um client or
customer based things that you do
outside of the eventually outside of the
Medicade space is that what is that what
you're saying you're sort of the
architecture will work for you can bolt
on something to and you can use it for
other client sets so to speak correct so
and not all of the moduls can you do
that with but the system integrator you
can
uh Pharmacy benefits management we used
to have two contracts one for public
health and one for Medicaid they were
doing very similar functions so we
combine them and they're in one RFP in
the future and there'll be one solution
one Pharm Pharmacy benefits management
system the data warehouse is another one
that we're leveraging as more of a
platform as opposed to a Medicaid
specific it's certainly initially funded
primarily by Medicaid so that we can get
it the onetime cost built out and then
SC scale it so we have to do cost
allocations and make sure that we are
upfront with our federal partners that
we're going to scale it and that if um
children youth and families decides to
use that warehouse they need to come up
with funds from Administration for
children and families and general funds
to do their expansion but it's Le much
less expensive to expand on an existing
platform and like if you take an analogy
of a building you can build a building
and then you can add different you can
split the rooms up with additional
internal walls cheaper than building
multiple buildings can I say you're
building a road and you can drive other
cars on
it that that's that's certainly how
system integrator would be yes okay
sorry good afternoon afterno I just
wanted to comment that um you know not
only is there potential reuse for some
of the stuff inside DHHS but also the
way we've been approaching together
which I do appreciate the collaboration
um other agencies in some cases can
leverage as well so we have examples uh
already where things that were you know
were invested in at
DHHS um you know maybe initially were
designed in a way that other agencies
could could use them and we're doing
that in a number of spaces the U
electronic business intelligence the
Salesforce standard standardizing on
that platform so uh the state as a whole
is benefiting from that approach not
so sorry I just had one other is this
going to be a uh cloud-based system or
will it be on-prem in the future
currently um the majority of these
Solutions are planned to be cloud-based
there might be some hybrid Solutions
depending on the needs and so that it
comes down to requirements so like the
data warehouse will certainly be a
hybrid solution at first but there might
be a transition to the cloud entirely
whereas the system integrator is planned
to be in the cloud entirely I was just
wondering if there's additional sort of
operating costs that you'll start to
incur that you don't have today or
savings from costs you have today that
you won't need in the future yeah
certainly so the operating cost on this
particular Capital request is about $15
million and that's for the Professional
Services to support the solution help
desk type support maintaining the cloud
infrastructure and being able to support
um additional enhancements at a very
like not major uplifts but upgrading
maintaining um the hardware maintaining
the software versions so that we don't
have to worry about that internally
where in in the past in many
organizations you don't fund the the
maintenance of it and then you have
systems that fail this that $15 million
which um our plan is to go through um
certification processes which we then
can be eligible to get 75% Federal match
for the Medicaid component and a smaller
match for the other divisions components
so it won't be an
exact um 75% it'll probably be a mix and
Mary CL behind me might have some
additional information if you want to
talk about that but we'll be working on
the cost allocation methodology as we go
forward would that be something that
would be in your um 2627 operating
budget or is it too soon to have that
because it's you're still maybe only
halfway through the project you we would
anticipate this one we would not
anticipate any operating expense in the
next panium uh we do anticipate some
operating expense from the system
integrator because that should be
implemented prior to the end of um next
year and so you'll see some some
operating from the current B anum's um
okay did you
have okay so then SL slide four the
modernized eligibility system Services
you'll you'll hear me say New Hampshire
easy or New Heights um those are our fun
terms for the integrated eligibility and
enrollment solution that um enables
people
to um take advantage of or not or or
apply for and be um determined for
eligibility for Medicaid tanif snap and
childcare and Wick programming
um it also supports recently we
implemented the developmental
disabilities and we're moving in the
aging and adult population system into
that
platform so one of the challenges we
have is that platform we've had it for a
little over what is it 24 years 25 years
and we contined to we've gone out to RP
twice in that time frame we continue to
enhance it and rep platform it to
maintain the health of that system but
one of the things that we haven't done
is really modernize and take advantage
of the digital um environment that we
could do today so for people to provide
U to um apply for services they have to
download a PDF and they can fill it in
and then they submit it whereas most
Technologies today you can type in the
information online click the submit and
it it puts it into the system and it's
more of a self-service F function ours
is a little bit more manual processing
where they fill out their application
they submit and then it goes to a person
to move it forward this Capital project
will allow for that digital self-service
um function to do multiple things
complaint and inquiry management but
also manage thirdparty
verifications do um really focus on our
Outreach using um SMS or text messaging
as well as email
Communications and then as I was talking
about forums dig
digitization really that's a a barrier
for a lot of people that are used to
technology I would say we will always
offer a paper process because it's
required by our federal Partners there
will always be an in-person option a
phone option and all the other options
but a large majority of our
beneficiaries are moving to cell phones
and internet-based services and so we're
trying to meet people where they're
at so I just wanted to add um this is a
critical uh piece Dave can speak to the
um technology side of it but this is a
real pinch point for the Department in
terms of determining eligibility in a
timely fashion so we're managing a lot
of consentuous um complaints and
concerns about that and part of that is
uh updating the system to be um in part
with in power with what the demand has
been so we automation is going to be one
way to speed that up um because we just
don't have the workforce right now to be
and again this one has a different um
Federal match so because of the
different programs that it supports and
like I was talking about um snap um
which is food stamps and TANF which is
cash assistance and um Medicaid and then
you have childcare Wick and then
developmental disabilities all of our
federal Partners give us different
funding based off of what their um
parameters are so you'll see that
Federal match is
okay Todd you want to come up and talk
to and I'm going to pass this over to
Todd really quick to speak to the Glen
system so as Todd's joining I just want
to preface that as we all know we're
looking as Charlie knows we're looking
at all safety throughout all of our
facilities so Glen Cliff is no exception
to that um and we do have some
vulnerable points here that uh need to
be addressed let Todd speak to that
hello I'm Todd bicker the uh executive
director of Glencliff home um thank you
for having me um this project is to
expand um a uh infant system that we
currently have um in 2017 we were able
to um install some interior cameras and
some magnetic locks on our doors um but
we weren't able to fully do our whole
campus um if you've ever been to GL home
we're pretty expansive we have 70 acres
and 22 buildings right now the two
resident buildings have the cameras in
in the locked doors um but we weren't
able to do the exterior or the other
buildings um and again
there's most of the buildings are
connected by tunnels there's 22
entrances to the resident areas and not
all of them are secure um and that does
not include the administration building
and meance buildings and all those other
buildings so this project is uh kind of
a combination of adding more cameras
uh adding more locked doors and then
expanding the wi-fi system right now we
only have Wi-Fi in the Resident areas
nowhere else on campus and again if
you've ever been to Glen clap we are
kind of remote we have no cell phone
coverage so right now if God forbid we
were to have an incident that similar to
what happened in New Hampshire hospital
areas wouldn't know um the laundry the
maintenance um other areas like that the
administration building would not be
made aware because there's no Universal
way to communicate to all of our staff
so this is like I said kind of a
combination of adding more um hard
barriers to exter exterior threats and
then um opening of communication so if
there we can have a better response to
any crisis it also um is would be
extremely helpful with the outside
cameras in case there's an internal
crisis such as a resident trying to
alope um or wander off right now we
would be able to identify which door
they went out but then that would be it
um so if we had some exterior cameras
then we'd be able to say see which dire
them I have a small question how what's
your current population uh today we're
at 71 um we have been capping our census
at 75 um out of 120 beds uh due to
Staffing uh we're still running about a
40% vacancy rate for nurses and lnas
it's a big issue everywhere I think um
is um you have no cell phone coverage I
this is a dumb technical question um but
I'm here to ask the dumb questions
um is is there no modern technology
where you
could put a thing that creates like a
mini hotspot kind of do you know what I
mean uh so I'm I'm at the same level as
you as technology okay um we might have
to ask Dennis this is where we turn to
Dennis and yes I think it's a dead zone
issue too isn't it yes
so so you can't wire into something and
create like a small
Zone um yes yeah you can do almost
anything with the appropriate amount of
money
oh well that's well
put we we have tried some of the lower
price like boosters um and you know we
can maybe get one bar on the top floor
right corner of the building um kind of
thing it doesn't work in my house either
yeah
thank
you continuing on the the next slide um
adrc I apologize for the acronym it's
aging disability Resource Center um
information and referral system sorry oh
and the the more common name that you
will hear that informational referral
system called is service link and
basically what that service link system
does is it connects um our aging
population with services and it's really
providing that information referral for
about just under 14,000 clients uh use
that caregiver program and that
solution's been in place for a little
over a decade actually probably more
like 15 years and it's been aging out
and and so we've been trying to submit
Capital Pro program to replace that
system so that we could maintain the
services but then leveraging tools like
the system integrator from the mees
program that we were talking about
earlier we would interface it with our
other systems so that we can understand
how people are getting admitted
discharged and transfer between
facilities as well as how they could get
referrals for other services using other
programs that we have in place so this
this system will really be focusing on
building that um solution to support
that individual and family directions
and and create that continuous quality
improvement for the client's needs I
think you have could you tell that I was
hovering over my microphone I wanted to
say something I just what I wanted to
point out is that we're uh in the middle
of implementing uh legislation from not
this session but last session regarding
establishing a system of care for Elder
uh for long-term support services so
this system is critical uh
infrastructure to running that system so
as as much as we also have the things
that we need to do we're required to
have the system to run this Tech system
to run that uh system of care that we're
standing
up I would just note that um we're
here's where we really miss Senator
delandro because he would he would at
this point give us a lecture on the
history of service link and how he was
here when it was implemented and I I
know I know that that's actually
something very near and dear to him and
the good news let's assume that was s
and he's across the hall if you want to
go hear it the good news is that we we
share the service link because we're
using the new acronym and the new name
and improving the whole system that is
long overdue for a rehaul so he would be
happy
actually so the the next slide is
multilanguage support for client notices
and this is really again another
addition to the new heights um
integrated eligibility and enrollment
system and one of the components there
is we're currently in violation of
several rights in terms of providing
notices in different U languages in our
state so 4.7% of our population doesn't
speak English however we are obligated
to translate um our notices into at
least the primary the primary and
secondary spoken language which is
Spanish as the secondary so this will
allow us to be compliant with the
federal requirements to support the use
of certain languages for communication
and it specifically allows for people
that don't speak English to be able to
read the notice and understand that they
were determinant and eligible for a
service and what the steps are that they
need to take in order to become eligible
for those
services this one is another one of
those um Capital butt projects that we
can seek 90% federal funds um to
implement and so it would have a general
fund impact of
$121,500 and a total dollar of
1,215
236 this is a very exacting number
because we have an existing contract
with the vendor and we we know what the
cost would be for this solution we would
need to seek an amendment for to for
work and then the next um Capital
project um that we have is a doent
management and
retention so this is really um focused
at supporting document management and
retention for the whole department we
have an existing system um that we
leverage for document management and
retention and it's been focused on Child
Care um sorry child support um children
youth and families long-term supports
and services and integrated eligibility
this would allow us to expand it to the
remaining um parts of our department to
allow for not only the ability to retain
records the way we are supposed to where
we have different um amounts of time in
order to retain them but able to re
access those records in a timely fashion
for different solutions like right to no
requests for 91a litigation requests um
associated with any type of court
hearing um as well as um moving forward
with providing case management support
for individuals to be able to retrieve
that information in a
manner this is one of those um projects
that we've been implementing
incrementally at over the many years and
this would get us over the hump to be
able to move forward for the whole
department um for doing document
management and
retention the the funding on this one is
estimated at 50% federal funds and this
that's because we would be seeking funds
across multiple divisions with um
and just to um reiterate it would be
really focused on retrieving data for
right to know if I didn't I if I did
miss that I apologize um but want to
make sure that I know we're all spending
a lot of time on on Discovery and and
finding a way to automate it obviously
saves staff time um that work not that
we're taking away from doing other
things
so with with the the 50% looks like
Federal match on this where's what
federal program is there that's
providing US money for documentation for
for document
retention so most of our federal
programs require us to maintain records
and so the way we would write the um
proposal to center for Medicare Medicaid
services as well as Administration for
Children and Families those are the two
primary Federal Partners would be that
in order to implement these systems that
we have sort um the Medicaid enterprise
system as well as the grant families or
Bridges solution that supports dcy
we need to maintain our documents and
and have that record retention component
and natively applications don't do
document retention you need a separate
system to do that that basically you say
this is a record it has a seven-year
retention after seven years destroy it
and it's not up it's not up to a case
manager to make that decision it's
usually in law that says this is how
long you're allowed to retain a record
medical records have a certain
determination of time and we have that
at the state level um we have a the
state librarian has published a a record
retention schedule that we're obligated
to follow but without this type of
solution it's really up to individuals
to figure out is this a 7 year or threee
20 year lifetime record it's really
difficult for us to manage with the
millions of records that we man that we
handle on a daily basis so I don't know
if I answered your question but most of
the funding would be coming the matching
dollars would be coming from
Administration for children families and
services and for the remaining two um
capital projects I was going to bring up
hospital
need good afternoon my name is Ellen Leo
I'm the CEO at New Hampshire hospital
and I get to give the elevator speech um
I couldn't resist I'm sorry so uh I
wanted to bring to your attention the
DHHS elevator Replacements uh four of
them are located at New Hampshire
hospital two of them are located at the
Anna Philbrook building which New
Hampshire hospital um has oversight of
for the past uh 3 years or so and is
actually at Glen Cliff home and Todd of
course is here if you have questions
about that one um but the concern is
that all of these elevators are original
to both New Hampshire hospital and the
Philbrook building so the four New
Hampshire hospital elevators were um put
in in early
1980s and we are not looking for total
elevator replacement what we're really
looking for is
modernization um to both the uh controls
and the power functions of these
elevators so that they can stay in
service we have unfortunately had
several occasions on a frequent basis
where one or more of these elevators are
out of service for a significant length
of time and they do disrupt patient care
as you can see three of them are
passenger elevators which patients do
utilize and one of them is our freight
elevator which is required to move
supplies and equipment throughout the
facility
um in regards to the two elevators at
the Anna Philbrook building um they are
also original to that facility and are
that much more aged having been put in
in the mid
1960s um these elevators are accessible
to both patients who reside in the NFI
Pathways program as well as to staff and
we do have um members of staff at that
building who are employed by New
Hampshire hospital who who who do
require utilization of the elevator due
to their
disabilities um so in general in that
elevator those elevators one of them in
particular has been down uh for the past
several weeks due to inability to repair
it and um obtain Parts given its age so
these are of a significant need for us
to be able to provide appropriate
patient
care I have a question on that maybe
this is a question that uh commissioner
Arling house might be able to answer and
that is you have these requests in in
your capital budget for these elevators
there's another request for the Brown
building elevators and the
commissioner's Bud capital budget
request why are some of hhs's elevators
coming from admin services and why are
some coming from HHS want me to do that
let see who can hit the button first um
the uh admin Services man manages uh
most state buildings we generally do not
manage the state buildings in which
people sleep on purpose um so um we call
it patient care well I was trying to
include Helen as well which isn't always
patient care but um so uh New Hampshire
hospital um because Anna Philbrook which
we used to manage and don't anymore is a
uh is a patient building now and then
transitional housings on the campus and
then Sena Center Glen
and something else which doesn't come to
Veterans Hampstead and newshire
Hampstead Hospital veterans
home so
Brown we take care of and the elevator
is just as bad I mean I I I feel I don't
mean to minimize how bad the elevators
are but um State elevators are a couple
of these I'm like wow that's bad and a
couple of them I'm like okay I don't
hello again um I'm back up for I believe
which is the last one which is the
Glencliff home fuel system upgrade it's
pretty straightforward um this is our
gas station basically that we have on
campus um that is over 28 years old and
it has um failed numerous inspections
but they have grandfathered it in
knowing that our system is no longer
able to provide um Parts last time we
repaired it we had to go to a DOT shop
that was decommissioning one of their
pumps and we stole some of the
components from borrowed some of the
components from them um basically uh we
have a fleet of 22 vehicles that we
maintain uh if we did not have this
source of fuel we would have to drive to
the nearest gas station and pay probably
15 to 20% more per gallon plus the time
of Staff in mileage um so this would
replace the pumps replace the tanks
replace the um spill management system
and currently the old pump is literally
in the middle of our grounds parking um
area with a telephone pull and low hung
wires which about 3 years ago did get
knocked down by a truck that went
through there so this would put all of
that type of things underground and make
it a much more safe um parking lot
area and just for those that don't know
it's a self- sustaining campus so the
reason why they have they do everything
I mean they generate their own
electricity and take care of everything
on site do our own snow plowing and all
things thank you very much don't see any
have questions so thank you very much
Department of
Corrections like to invite you up for
you good afternoon commissioner good
afternoon good afternoon honorable
members of the state for the record my
name is Helen Hanks I'm the commissioner
of the Department of Corrections to my
right is Heidi laramy our administrator
of logistics it is my great privilege to
talk to you about the capital budget
infrastructure for the Department of
Corrections um the PowerPoint uh that
we're passing out before you on slide
two is literally a summary of the 15
priority projects I'm going to talk
about uh today and I wanted to emphasize
the total amount saved for deferred
projects if the state moves forward with
replacing the New Hampshire state prison
for men is a approximately $91
million uh cost of projects that we
believe we cannot uh postpone is $18.7
million and of that 8 $18.7 million
there may be another 7 million we could
postpone and I'll talk about that as we
go through the
presentation U moving on to the next
slide our priority number one project
and I would like to pause and take a
moment and thank Senator gray is a prime
sponsor of a bill that put forward
legislation this year uh that received
the
support of the legislature in a unique
roundabout way but a $40 million
allocation will be headed to the
governor's desk to continue the groundw
that we need to do to diligently put a
cost proposal forward to the state to
replace the New Hampshire state prison
for men um that is priority number one
the original structures built in
1878 um are still being used uh and in
addition to our reception and diagnostic
area originally built in 1940 referred
to as the annex is still in use every
single day um as the primary booking
location for men who are incarcerated
with in Hampshire Department of
Corrections there were major Renovations
in the
1980s uh to our special housing unit our
closed custody unit our secure
psychiatric unit our residential
treatment unit um and it continued on
with our medium custody North medium
custody South so on and so forth with
our Hancock building coming in the
1990s uh newer uh industry Renovations
and buildings and some you know they
there's a hodge podge of infrastructure
on that campus and as a result uh we
continue to see physical plant uh
surprises like I've never seen
architecturally including ramps that are
roofs uh that are over our kitchen area
um ramps that are roof over staff entry
points into facilities um mold
remediation projects that uh occur that
I have to find paths forward to um roofs
literally being blown off
um we have actually um we
have short block veneer that is mounted
to concrete and the bolts that secure
that veneer to the concrete are rusted
away some of those uh are 35 ft High we
continue to monitor those for fear
they're going to fall off the concrete
walls um the the laundry list of issues
on that campus is significant and I I do
want to continue to remind people the
mission of the Department of Correction
is provide infrastructure that's
rehabilitative safe and Humane and I'm
going to continue to Advocate to replace
the newshire state prison for men so we
meet that mission we can have a facility
that is efficient with technology that
affords staff on a day like this where
we're sitting in an air conditioned
Suite uh the New Hampshire state prison
for men's staff are working hard 247 in
hot ruling locations in addition to the
individuals incarcerated in that
infrastructure um
so I I will not continue on because I
know this is first of many conversations
on this
project priority number two is
additional funding for our steam lines
and traps it is clear uh as we've worked
through existing steamline projects we
have sub continue to have substantial
leaks um and mechanical issues that have
been found because our partners uh in
conquered are letting us know that we
have abnormally high water usage um and
we're finding those leaks in the
existing project we can continue to need
to replace the steam lines uh some of
those Pathways also still date back to
1878 uh those projects are expensive uh
because you have to dig through the
concrete yard uh and all sorts of coal
Pockets that pre-exist that physical uh
plants
infrastructure I think the pictures
really speak for
themselves priority number three I'm
going to take a Twist on you and talk
about our New Hampshire correctional
facility for men in Berlin it is time to
replace the body alarm system that is
called a personal duress system I also
call it a manown system um the company
Bosch that provided our original system
in 2000 no longer uh provides this
product you cannot buy this product it
is a primary defense for our staff and
that institution to alert that they are
in duress and they need emergency
response uh so our Correctional line
Personnel who are nurses or social
workers or case managers or teachers
these systems are critical when you run
a correctional institution we replace
about 20 a year uh and we need to
upgrade this product so we continue to
provide safety resources to the staff uh
dedicated within that
institution priority number four is the
Hampshire state prison for men see how I
brought you back to that infrastructure
uh talking about our electronic controls
and our camera installation this is
really part number two of a
facility-wide replacement of our old
analog to a digital uh system there's a
lot of money um that needs to be spent
on wiring digital head-in equipment uh
these are uh belong in a museum as you
can see on priority number four uh we
ran short of money to complete that
project and so this amount of money
would afford US to replace approximately
301 uh cameras these are absolutely
critical for both transparency awareness
we continue to pass our prison rape
elimination act audit because we can see
things and places that are critically
important and this continues to build on
that I was just in the institution last
week a fight broke out if we did not
have the cameras we could not have seen
what the instigation event was we could
not be able we would not be able to move
forward and press charges for the
assault on my staff um so these cameras
augment the safety of the institution
and that's why they're priority number
four priority number five is to replace
the fire alarm systems uh uh Miss laramy
came forward to let me know this fine
news uh this is for approximately
400,000 square fet of fire alarm systems
across both the Men's prison campus
transitional housing units and some
other docc facilities what we have
learned from working with several
outside vendors is that from previous
work we found a myriad of issues of
wiring injunction boxes that have no
Rhyme or Reason that we um don't
understand how they were Wired from one
place to another uh it is failing and it
creates false alarms uh does not give us
the solidarity that a fire alarm when it
goes off is truly a fire we don't need
to create emergencies in an institution
where an emergency is something we take
uh very clearly um at the Forefront of
our work um this uh project will replace
existing systems put in new code
compliant uh fire alarm systems and
obviously that's a critical issue when
you have 1,500 people charged in your
responsibility on our Southern
campus priority number six used to be
the HVAC units that use R2 refrigerant
R2 refrigerant was federally banned by
the EPA in 2010 it had a 10-year plan
where in 2020 they were no longer
legally allowed to produce our 2020 the
only thing you can do now is get
reclaimed r2020 for systems that they're
taking down and use used
r2020 um so we need to replace at least
eight large HVAC units on the New
Hampshire state prison for men and their
related components to continue to
provide air filtration system on that
campus priority number seven is to
replace the reception and diagnostic
building and the diagnostic reception
and diagnostic building houses over 120
individuals it's capable of doing that
um the building is referred to as a van
dorm style building I can hear John
Hansen's voice in my head he is very
interested in this aged architecture it
does not exist anywhere else uh it is
definitely a historical location um and
it has uh challenges both in that there
are the bars themselves in an area where
the risk of suicide is already imminent
because you're newly booked or returning
that is scientifically demonstrated
through Corrections you can tie things
on here it is not an automated or
electrical system you have to use levers
to pop these doors open and those are no
longer reliable the chase ways for rep
are a challenge the plumbing in this
space is a challenge we are challenged
to find someone to repair current leak
uh in addition to U the exterior walls
have cracks you can see through we're
challenged wondering about the brick
veneer on the outside um this space
period it doesn't even afford US proper
processes to properly screen newly
booked individuals um you know we've had
instances where people have uh almost
brought in cell phones and other items
just yesterday in a tragic uh news event
in the Georgia Department of Corrections
someone brought in a handgun that was
used to kill a kitchen worker in their
Correctional institution and some of
those things happen literally because
you don't have good screening procedures
processes and physical plant um we need
to remove those challenges and enhance
the security and safety in these
institutions there are real tragedies we
can avoid
priority number seven uh I already did
that one didn't I I'm just showing you
more pictures priority number eight this
one seems really little uh this is a
5,000 uh gallon non-compliant diesel
tank we want to remove this underground
diesel storage tank it leaks uh it needs
to be taken away it has um lasted they
what has the they last about 25 years I
mention to guess how long you think
that's been there um it was installed in
1994 so it is beyond its useful life we
want to replace it actually with an
above ground storage uh diesel tank for
the use uh right outside our warehouse
facility moving on to Priority number
nine we have been working steadily
through the guidance of the Department
of Labor with commissioner Maryfield to
replace our boilers this is the last of
three boilers that we need to uh provide
steam to the conquered Men's prison it
is beyond its repair and uh needs to be
replaced the boiler is over 40 years old
it's a Cleaver Brooks tube style boiler
uh those typically have a life
expectancy of 25 years so we've really
gotten our money's worth at this point
um the Dr Rader and surge uh tanks are
also 40 years old and they also are
prone to leaking so we need to replace
that priority number 10 continues around
our security perimeter systems and
fences at the New Hampshire state prison
for men wall and detection systems
clearly it's our first point of
awareness both of somebody's trying to
get out and that somebody who's not
supposed to come in is trying to come in
we did receive an apportionment uh but
that only took us a short distance of
linear feet and we continue to have
infrastructure problems on our fence
detection that I will not go into public
detail
on priority number 11 is a sample of one
of many control rooms at the New
Hampshire state prison for men so as you
can imagine working in a space um and I
I think she politely took out the part
where there's an actual toilet in that
space and in some spaces there is no
toilet um individuals who are working in
these 24-hour spaces the technology that
we've Advanced is good but the spaces in
which we've put them do not have air uh
or cooling control so we are actually
causing a risk to the efficiency we're
getting by adding technology because we
don't have enough HVAC and
infrastructure control to to cool and de
dehumidify the spaces when a staff
member is in a control room where there
is no facilities they wait over
approximately 15 minutes to be relieved
to go relieve themselves um and we need
to create a better system uh as we look
at these control rooms and try to help
staff uh work through the nuances of the
old agent infrastructure and we need to
make sure that the technology we've
implemented uh continues to be a
resource and that we don't degrade it
because our fiscal plant is doing
that uh priority number 12 is to replace
the electrical
Transformers uh we've had those uh hip
hipi lightning in 2017 one of my first
moments uh working with commissioner
Arling house uh it was struck by
lightning I found out the age of those
Transformers We also um had a split in
electrical lines in the ground where the
El the electricity leaked into the
ground and individuals could have been
electrocuted and died I'm not
catastrophizing these are the real
things that we deal with in correct so
please know that um the uh we just had
another Transformer uh during a storm
event uh blow and we've had to find old
Transformers to replace them but
ultimately we need to replace the
electrical eight electrical Transformers
to something current and modern um that
is sustainable and that we don't
literally have to drive to Ohio to find
one uh priority number 13 is a continued
request we received arpa funding for our
meting custy South and North general
population units those house the largest
number of individuals at the New
Hampshire state prison for men uh but we
need to continue to work on replacing
our air handlers and duck work
throughout the institution they are
rusted they are corroded uh we talked
about I shared with you the number of
years of architectural builds over time
some of these are built in places where
they didn't connect them correctly
they're actually underrated for the
workload they need to produce um they're
retrofitted in attic spaces and other
spaces that uh have had Rhyme or Reason
then but as the infrastructure in the
plant expanded they do not now um so
many of them need to be upsized and
relocated uh but many of them need
simply to be replaced because they are
imminently falling down or have fallen
down they need to have fans Motors belts
and other related equipment replaced and
they are beyond their
repair I'm almost done with this
exciting Good News uh priority number 14
is to replace the corre grade security
Windows vents facility
wide Correctional grade windows are not
Windows you can just take out and repair
like in your home these are uh concrete
rebar cemented into the infrastructure
purposely done so so you cannot get out
of them but in the course of doing that
in order to replace them you have to
concrete cut through those windows we
still need to incarcerate need to then
secure back up the window while you
replacing the window this is a
methodical process that would have to
occur across the whole
campus uh this project is the one that
depending on a rebuild we would try to
put it off for as long as we can um in
addition these windows are secured so
when the self-directed ventilation that
is installed in them breaks where the
resident can control the air moving in
or the air moving out in our four
seasoned uh location uh that becomes a
problem so if they lock in place and I
can't get them open the air moving in
and out doesn't continue to happen when
it's the winter it's going to happen and
it's going to be cold and we have to try
to work around those things this is 832
Windows across this campus in all sorts
of
locations um the other very important
part these windows um literally it's
hard to see through them anymore so line
of sight to make sure the things
happening in that room or what should be
happening become very challenging um and
I I can't understate that that's a
safety issue as
well here we are priority number 15 I
told you I was only going to talk about
15 of them uh we drive around our campus
we drive around our campus we need to
repair and repave these roads as I
replace our vehicles we are actually
damaging our new vehicles because the
roads have such poor uh Road quality to
them that we're hitting potholes drains
um and drain Edge have sunk we have
major problems across the perimeter
roads we go around and round the road
every single day in addition to uh the
par parking lots that exist on the
campus where both uh staff and those
tending parole hearings uh go to those
have those are seven parking lots they
haven't been paved in over 30 years and
some of the initial Paving was literally
just a skim coat over a gravel parking
lot because that's what they could
afford um so the road conditions are
causing a damage to our permited
vehicles they have not been maintained
the soils beneath some of the um uh
drainage ways need to be examined and
replaced and that is what priority
number 15 is all about so with that I'm
certainly happy to answer any questions
clarify okay or just leave you in
a I have many questions um the first one
is just to just to get an overview you
have the the men's replacement of the
Men's prison then you have a lot of
upgrades to the existing prison is this
an either or do the Men's prison or we
need these upgrades or we have these
we're going to need a Men's prison be
built and we need these upgrades now so
on the second thank you for that
question on the second slide we put an
aster next to projects um that we don't
feel we can postpone and that again
accounts for about 18.7 million that
page looks like
this that could be potentially Reduce by
another 7 million if we can put off the
windows project uh but those are things
that we need to continue to ask for
funding for while the uh process occurs
regarding a replacement facility for the
New Hampshire state presis for men so
there is about $91 million I can tell
you today that depending on the build of
that project and moving date we are
we're hopeful of working toward avoiding
expending that and using those funds
toward a replacement facility rather
than the infrastructure we have today
okay uh this question is is is a bit
complicated in the fact that the prison
is $580 million you receive $10 million
in the budget last year you you're about
to get another $40 million from the bill
that Senator gray sponsored
uh which leaves you $530 million
short um as the governor mentioned in
his opening statement we normally give
$120 million per per bium and for the
capital budget which if we gave every
penny to The Men's prison that would
take about four and a half bi enums or
or close to nine years to get it done uh
I know you've had conversations both
with myself and with the state treasurer
um yes if you could Enlighten us on are
you working on a plan that that would uh
enable you to meet your financing goals
yeah thank you V that been working with
State Treasurer and her team they've
been uh very helpful in understanding
this is a unique project for the State
uh we we both agreed verbally that this
would require separate legislative
language so that the state treasurer
could look at something more like a 20
or 30 a year and I'm going to equate it
to a mortgage or bond in that Essence
because the the life expectancy of a new
replacement uh facility would outweigh
the life of that Bond and the return on
investment would would balance that
action so she and I are very much um
hand inand in discussing how the state
could move forward without impacting the
current capital budget process but it
would have to be supported through
separate legislation and a more uh
specifically targeted language much like
the language we created for the $40
million using that concept but also
understanding that a new
facility given the years and discussions
I just had with you would have a lot
longer life uh uh than 30 years okay and
given the complications here of getting
the financing and obviously the
complications that will arise and
actually constructing the
facility if if everything goes according
to the best case scenario time frame you
have in your mind what are we looking at
for a completion date for this project
assuming you can get the the financing
in a reasonable amount of time that you
would expect and then the construction
after that yeah I would work hand inand
with members of Ted Copper's team and
our experience both learned experience
and lived experience with in Hampshire
correctional facility for women so that
we don't relive things that were not
good steps there but I would hope that
between the work we're doing now and uh
a 10-year period we would be moving very
steadily forward to to knowing a movein
date um if that is certainly an absurd
speculation I want that man to certainly
chime in but I think if all hands were
involved in moving in an expedition way
and there was support for the
legislation to fund it um I don't think
a 10-year plan would be out of the realm
of
possibilities see the nod we good
questions um hi hi on priority number
five on the slide it says all applicable
Southern States in parentheses sites
yeah sites yeah what does that mean yep
so that's when I discussed that uh it's
New Hampshire state prison for men our
transitional housing units they all need
their uh fire alarm systems upgraded and
I am forgetting a location so there our
transitional work center okay all right
I thought I'd ask about the
prison
um um so we built a women's prison
recently at least I think it's recently
right we moved in in
2018 is it that long ago I guess it
would be yeah after the locks worked um
the uh uh it it's it's one building it's
one prison and it houses how many people
ballpark it was sized for 2 24 224 and
and a new Men's prison would be sized
for about so part of the $50 millionar
would do the programmatic analysis and
look at population progression uh yeah
progressions and right now the state
prison for men has approximately 1,200
people incarcerated there in 2010 and 11
if we change any legislation around
sentencing we've housed up to 17 to
18800 so looking at population is
absolutely contingent on what the state
is doing with regard to felony
sentencing would you would you build
would you build one
prison or would you build
um I don't know exactly how to express
what I'm what's in my head but
um that mean one of the things that
happens is you have it's not one giant
building right right um is are there
savings to be had I don't mean from a
building stand point but operationally
or whatever from something that
resembles modular or you have four
buildings on the same site that are you
know like you know like you like you go
to a big college and they don't except
in a really stupid giant State School
have one giant dorm right they have like
eight yeah does that make some sense is
there opportunity there well
commissioner AR knows your question is
absolutely um relative to what that $50
million will buy us uh one part uh that
people people should be aware of when
you look at a campus style of of
infrastructure where there are multiple
buildings you have to look at all the um
the plumbing and electrical and all
those lines you're creating and then you
have to look at the Staffing so if I'm
Staffing six buildings and I can gain no
efficiency I'm almost in the same
situation I am now um without talking
about technology so I'm not going to be
able to answer your question about what
the right build is but the $50 million
is supposed to help us get to that with
bid speec documents it's one of the
things you're looking at with that to
say how can I make a staffing more
efficient how can I make if I 1,200
people instead of, 1600 people yeah and
by nature of having different
classification levels where people are
more high risk versus low risk there
will be a physical plant separation but
I'm hesitant to try to speculate on how
that would look with buildings at this
point and you've seen significant
reduction in the number of people
incarcerated in the last what 10 15
years in that range absolutely we have
done a great job as a state in looking
at both incarceration rate and Public
Safety both through specialty courts and
all of the actions across the state to
see over a 28% reduction in the overall
incursor of
population are those largely policy
driven or is some of it societal they're
policy driven it's also the state uh the
Department of Corrections deserves
accolades we've reduced our recidivism
rate by 7% since 2018 and we continue to
see a reduction ction because we're
targeting one primary area that causes
people to return to incarceration and
that's both substance use disorder and
substance misuse so both with the work
we're doing while someone's incarcerated
and the re-entry work we're doing post
relase we're we're reducing people's
return to incarceration which has been
the state's systemic problem um and in
addition to the work we're doing with
the Department of Health and Human
Services seeking uh centers for Medicaid
and Medicare s uh Services waiver under
the 1115a to build continued strong
Bridges to re-entering the community
we're both making great policy decisions
but operational decisions and
collaboration decisions um like the rest
of us you have an aging population I
think I think that um the way in which
people think about age is not the same
in incarceration so the life choices
that I might engage in if I'm a person
who has had repeat interactions with the
justice system is going to impact me
differently when I'm getting hepatitis C
and other um things so I want to be
careful that aged Inc Corrections could
be more like 55 and not aged like 65
plus depending on what that matter is
and I know people of all ages that are
quite healthy but to the point of the
matter we're facing the treatment of
chronic illnesses associated with both
substance use disorder and lack of
attention to Health Care issues whether
it's type 2 diabetic hypertension uh
hepatitis C HIV um and uh the course of
the effect of OB use disorder on the
body in in general though your your
population has probably um higher Health
Care needs than the population as a
whole y that is very fair to say and
again reminding us that the cost of our
healthc care and incarceration is to the
general fund um and that Medicaid only
covers impatient eligible stays um when
when we think of you know a lot of us
when we think of a a prison tend to I'm
going to date myself here tend to think
of Otis on The Andy Griffith Show right
and it's just a you know center block
cell with a with you know a door that
happens to be made out of bars but it's
much more complicated than that to to
some extent do you have um um housing
requirements housing issues where where
the person though incarcerated unable to
to leave for a for the day is not in a
setting that looks stereotypically
prison like because of the healthcare
issues it's more hospital is well it's
fair to say even our infirmary at the
New Hampshire state prison for men needs
to be updated so it it looks like a room
where we put four hospital beds it's got
seethrough windows so we can see what's
happening but we need more um I'll call
it central uh service space to the point
of your question deal with those health
conditions right now it is a renovated
space that is a a large uh rectangular
angular space that used to be a Cell
Block that was converted to a health
services space so to be mindful and as a
good example the Hampshire correctional
facility for women we designed that with
rehabilitation in mind and when I talked
about the recidivism rate the recidivism
rate for women is decreasing faster than
the recidivism rate for men we moved
into the nire correctional facility for
women in 2018 their recidivism rate is
looking from what used to be a high 40
uh 46% to closer to 30% so the
infrastructure matters in addition to
all the other things I've said when you
look specifically at men you have to
look at how the infrastructure is
impacting the delivery of Rehabilitation
at the same time well that's interesting
I didn't I thought you'd find that
interesting yeah and and you seem to
incarcerate many many many many more men
than you do women sir I don't
incarcerate anyone the judicial system
does I accept them based on the
sentencing order sir
welome just pointing that out it just
seems unfortunate I don't maybe that
says something about men well you're
more statistically likely to be iners
than I am then based on that statistic
right yeah well let's not go too far
from this I just wanted to say something
Sil any other
questions thank you very much for your
time and next up in uh ending today's
session is going to be uh Department of
Information
[Laughter]
Technology good afternoon um afternoon
sir Dennis goule uh the commissioner of
the Department of Information Technology
uh just have three requests to go
through with you today uh the summaries
on the on the second
slide as usual cyber security is number
one um and you know I don't expect that
to change I each by each bium I've come
with my first priority being cyber
security and that reflects the my peers
around the country who vote vote cyber
have voted uh cyber security as their
number one priority for over a
decade so moving on to slide three um so
high level each each uh year month day
you know the pace seems to be
increasing but our enemies and the
criminals just keep you know getting
better at defeating whatever we put in
to protect data but also protect
continuity of government and that's a
big change that we've seen over the past
just the past few years where um you
know it used to be we'd be concerned
with oh there was a data breach people's
data is out there and that's a concern
for the privacy of data but um now very
much um we're concerned with um
continuity of government U this the most
basic is you know where U you know a
what they call a business email
compromise where somebody gives up their
credentials and and actually allows
criminals to take money which then is
money you might have spent running the
government um and we've seen that in in
around New Hampshire and around the
country U but but more severe is
ransomware which um we're seeing you
know really put entire you know school
systems out of business we've seen you
know police departments be shut down and
running manual for months you know going
from complex sophisticated dis batching
systems to paper so it's something that
we take exceptionally
seriously and
really each bium we're looking at what
do we think the appropriate investment
level is in new tools and
procedures so that we'll try to at least
stay up with this and then you'll see
subsequent operating expense being
layered on in the the subsequent bium so
little by little actually the amount
we're spending on cyber security is
creeping up on bial on a banial
basis um so the one of the things where
we've noticed and we're having to spend
more time on and and you'll see that
reflected in the first paragraph is the
you know we connect up to um other law
enforcement agencies to share
information we connect up with our um
with our municipalities to do vehicle
registration and things like you know
interfaces so if something happens in
their environments it puts a risk to our
environment so getting better at
noticing that protecting that is part of
what we're doing but also with the state
and local cyber grant program monies
that's Federal monies that was that were
um appropriated under the infrastructure
bill um we're investing in those
communities to improve their cyber
posture as well so kind of hitting it
from both sides this money is not
being asked for to do anything in
municipalities the state and local cyber
grant program monies which we're in year
two now we've gotten through the the
accept and expend process for for year
two of that money I think the total is a
little over 14 million over four years
and we're hoping that that the the
federal government will will reup that
Grant when when the time comes when
we're approaching the end of it
um so really um without going into the G
this is pretty geeked out stuff I Tred
to give you a high level um explanation
of what we're trying to do and I'll stop
and take questions on cyber security
on Dennis this is more of a general
question but um previous Capital budgets
how much has have you received in the
last let's say maybe two I&M or do you
have any sense I want to say it's around
it's a it's a little under $4 million
over the last two Bay year yeah
okay thanks and
we we we're consistently spending it
say Okay moving on um it service
management that's a um as a concept it
service management or itm uh because we
love acronyms in state government um is
really uh the
maturation of how we Define and deliver
service IT
services um you know there are areas
where New Hampshire is ahead of other
states and we and and this isn't one of
them uh so we're we've been using old
you know old tools and
processes um and partly because it's
kind of expensive to to get from where
we are to where we think we should be in
terms of that maturity level um Last by
anym we said all right well let's start
and do phase one which is was really
around the you know defining what it is
looking at our existing processes things
like that and we're we're in we're well
um down the path of doing that right now
this request would then continue the
effort by beginning to layer in those
tools um and and
uh and I would think that there'd be a
phase three so we're trying to break it
down so that it's not you know hugely
impactful in anyone by any of but also
it makes sense to do so because changing
you know the significant change that
we'd have to implement to how we do
business both for ourselves as well as
how we interact with all our agency
partners is pretty it's a pretty large
task so you can't get it done in a one
by anym
anyway so um stop there Dennis can you
give us an example of like a like a
specific thing that either you did or
about to do like this isn't us system
it's a series of projects it's actually
not the system's kind of the it's
necessary but not sufficient it's not
it's not that in other words the biggest
thing is the business processes that we
use to to deliver services and and I'll
give you a I'll give you an example that
if you're doing if you interact with us
on if there's any like agency Finance
people they they would get this I know
James and I have talked about this
before where you know I don't understand
that doit budget because it's you know
it's you just for a PC there might be 20
line items for the cost of a single PC
well that's kind of overly complicated
and not really reflective of what we do
should we be billing you so just on the
billing side we probably should be say
all right well here's the fully loaded
cost of a PC and here's what it is and
and hide all that complexity from the
Finance people inside the um inside the
um agency so that's an example of a a
matured it service management process
it's a really simple one uh but but
that's kind of an example of that so to
do that you need systems because you
actually need to be able to build up
these bills of materials that are um you
know what's the fully loaded cost of a
you know some states do this they a
network Port like you have a network
Port that you might plug your PC in
um that that is um required to get on
the network if that actually has so much
infrastructure behind it but what we're
doing is we're we're managing those as
discret elements versus a you know a
holistic
service um and costing them as well
so so that's I and U you know we have a
we have a contractor expert we brought
on to help us with this and if you're
interested Charlie I can set up a
meeting you you'd find it pretty
interesting I can go through this in
excuting
technical other questions on
this all right so the last one is is
what the heck is this Cloud thing Cloud
Solutions and services so it's
interesting but um the so we have a data
center at 27 hay it's pretty old and um
we haven't really uh we haven't really
asked for much money for it because we
haven't put a system in there a new
system in there since the revenue system
Rim system that was purchased I think
it's been it was that contract was done
about 5 years ago and um they've been
running the system now for I think three
years right it took a couple years to
get it running so think about that in
the old days every new system boom you'd
be putting new gear in the data center
you'd be expanding the
footprint everything that uh agencies
are acquiring now is all as a service so
Sher your question about the Medicaid
stuff I mean the vast majority of all
that will end up you know I'm certain
being in the cloud um although we you
know HHS we we do actually have a
strategic conversations about how we're
going to do things with them because
they're our obviously our biggest
customer but but what what that's caused
is you know in the days of data center
we had to learn how to do things like
backing up and you know um making copies
of data and doing Disaster Recovery
playing and all that so this these Cloud
Solutions and services are really the
layered services that we're we're
finding that we have to add to to kind
of manage this new infrastructure that
we live in today um liquor just went
live with a new system for their um
Finance inventory and retailing their
stores business to B Toc business to
customer and B and B Tob businessto
business transactions all of that is in
the cloud except for the you know if you
go into a liquor store you'll see
equipment there but other than that all
of that's in the cloud and that's a
pretty huge system op operating in the
cloud and and so what we've learned
there or what we are learning and
everybody's learning all the states and
and the businesses and the private
sector is that it's a it's a different
set of skills inside your the people
that are running it it's a it's a
different set of tools that you need to
manage overall and provide productivity
and governance
because one of the mistakes we have New
Hampshire wasn't a what they call a
cloud first state there's kind of
terminology Cloud first Cloud smart
Cloud first was yeah go to Cloud no
matter what and we're like well why
right and I was thinking why and then
the the folks who were a little slower
and more ponderous like us or I call it
Cloud smart because we were thinking
about well do it when it needs to be
done not when it um when it um you know
when you just because cloud is there and
so that's kind of how we've been
approaching it you know
opportunistically when a system is being
replaced um if Hardware is aging out for
example um you know the employment
security is has a really you know a very
good unemployment system Unemployment uh
Insurance system one of the very few in
the country that that was able to scale
to the to the needs of covid but their
Hardware is aging so do you buy new
hardware and plunk it in a data center
or do you do you host it in the cloud
and it's likely that you know George and
Rich will decide to host in the cloud so
that's an example those
as we do more and more of that we're
learning the skills and and and kind of
supporting services and capabilities
that we'll need to make sure that is is
as secure and as um available and as
well governed at least as what we were
doing in our own Data Center and that's
kind of the essence of this investment
and we we actually had a similar
appropriation that we asked for I
believe to by any ago that's we we're
well into to invest that those
Investments and we believe we'll
continue be be needing to continue to do
that
so um I'm curious about this right
because on some level you know I think
the 27 part of haen Drive was was built
as Central data processing right I think
that when that was a term um um and I
think Su Luba worked there went from the
start so our our favorite do
employee um other than you other than me
is Su Lu good to know yeah um although
I'll tell Sue that she's my favorite not
you just so you know don't you
um we it you know we you think of it as
as a place where all of the states data
is and I
remember six or eight years ago somebody
talking about how oh yeah data's at at
you know 27 Hazen I think that's not a
secret and then there's a backup site on
the other side of the river at
Toby or somewhere I don't even know
where and and I thought oh great so if
the electric all goes down for all of
conquered we're screwed um the but we're
evolving from a world where it matters
where your data is and I'm paying for
servers for New Hampshire first right
and there's a there's a guy somewhere in
the bowels of your building who's like
going you know like Lily Tomlin with the
uh with the uh operator phone but we're
moving to a place where our data won't
be be here it'll all be out there
somewhere which sounds both
safer right cuz there's multiple places
the data exists it doesn't just you know
if the if the if a light if lightning
strikes 27 Hazen we're not out of luck
it's it's buried in a mountain in New
York or somewhere but it's also a little
bit
um uh vulnerable cuz it's not here we
don't have a copy we don't have a I
don't have a sheet why why should I be
why should I be happy and is there a
balance between those two things or is
the cloud just where we're going and I'm
not not some sort of weird Battle Star
Galactica thing where blow us it's a
it's a good example that you brought up
because that's part of what we're
investing in here is these you know
whether it's the um that extra copy you
say Okay um you know I know for example
a liquor is you know they're running
their finance and and point of sale on
Microsoft 365 they have an automatic
copy that you know if if the main their
main data center would to go down
there's another one that for their
production system that Microsoft has
running at all all times so that's nice
but you know we look at um you know do
we want another copy of that and in the
case of liquor they're going to have a
copy that is for reporting for example
much like you know for first we have the
data Lake uh um that I'm sure Alex has
talked to you about and and similarly
with liquor similarly with um DHHS with
their ebi electronic business
intelligence that we talked a little bit
about earlier so so yeah that's you you
have the the mistake that a lot of folks
made particularly the cloud first is
they said oh it's in the cloud I don't
need to worry about anything that's
that's not correct you need to worry
about the same things in different ways
you want to make sure you have access to
your data like I I'll just share a
consideration we were talking to to Rich
labors at Employment Security about is
okay as we move we could actually put it
in a different database and save money
you know instead of giving a huge huge
amounts of money to Oracle for the
database we give less huge amounts to
AWS for their native database all right
but what does that mean in terms of my
ability to get it back when I want it
does that actually constrain me at all
or is it just as easy um but the but
essentially you know if I'm running uh
as far as accessibility of data the the
tools and the systems that they're
running on in the cloud are the same
ones I'm essentially the same as I'm
running on here so you can do the
querying of data the access of data the
backing up of data all of that stuff you
know it can be done there's no um uh
there's there's been some legal battles
around you know Kenya Kenya cloud
provider hold your data hostage uh no
and you got to make sure that they can't
in contracts right but but no I mean
it's your data it's not theirs unless
you make a mistake in in you know in an
agreement and allow them to have that
but our Agreements are typically pretty
clear about you know ownership of the
data as well as any special intellectual
property that we develop that we invest
in and develop for ourselves so like
back in the day I could I had an
external Zip drive mhm am I dating
myself um the uh cuz I could get like
five six eight Meg of data on one extra
thick three and 1 half inch floppy and
uh but it was mine I did that I put it
on this disc I did it twice right
because I wanted to make sure my hard
drive that I wasn't just relying on
Windows 98 to back up my hard drive for
me that I was but I had it but it was
mine and whatever happened unless
somebody came too close to me with a
magnet it was mine
and um I I I hear you saying that we we
don't really have those issues with the
cloud at any point are there
Financial hostage taking I'm going to
use one of my so I I'm not an enormous
fan of the the Washington Corporation
Called Microsoft um that um you used to
used to buy a piece of software and you
could keep it as long as you were
willing to go with it for a while and
now they came up with a new scheme where
they make you pay money every year to
keep it up and and you reached the point
where you're sort of Hostage CU you
can't switch right you you there are
certain softwares where at some point
you're like oh my God I don't think I
can ever get out of this and I'm sort of
stuck like I can't what would it cost to
repr procure a
new MMI system Erp pick something and
when we go Cloud clish on everything is
is there any of that is that a concern
at all or is it is that sort of
overblown
well there's a couple things one one is
that the biggest part of switching isn't
actually the technology it's the effort
you have to go through like even you
know like to like like we're doing now
with your Erp system it's still a lot of
work um yes but that and that would be
the same work whether we were doing it
inside my own data center at 27 Hazen or
I'm doing it inside somebody else's it's
the same work um they the consolidate in
the industry is to me is the
biggest um you know consolidation and
dirty tricks inside the industry which
have always been there they're just
different now in in the cloud for
example um you can in fact there was a
sen Senate Bill
210 um I think was passed by both bodies
um which really it's called the the um
it was sponsored by it was pushed by the
coalition for fair software
licensing um says you know they object
to the fact that um some software
companies will charge a different amount
subscription cost for if it's hosted in
their own environment versus somebody
else's so for example if you have an
Oracle database and you want to host it
in AWS or
Google um Oracle will charge you more
than if you host it in their own Data
Center and so some people think that's
unfair some people think that's um you
know a business being smart and and
leveraging the competitive advantage of
their investments in vertical
integration so um but you know moving
out of Microsoft uh seven states have
done it and moved all over to Google a
lot of work systems aren't quite as good
but you can do it but those are the only
two in the world right so you say if you
don't like mic of Google where you going
to go we're not doing open software or
whatever that build like 10 years ago
for we're all supposed to use open
Office yeah there's a l there were two
two uh two sessions in a row there were
a number of Open Source bills so the
open source folks would say there's
another option I don't share that
feeling for you know for email and
collaboration and things like that I
don't think related to ask number one
cyber
security yeah shut up now so I'm you
know and and and Charlie the the subs
two more things um it it how we feel
about cloud and you know there's pluses
and
minuses um everybody's moving to it
there in many cases there's you you you
can't buy a product that isn't in the
cloud in fact even know the revenue that
system fast systems who has our Revenue
in in 27 Hazen the last system that was
placed in there their new their new
installations are all being done in a
cloud environment um and the there's
almost no what you call Perpetual
license agreements anymore that was the
you buy at once and pay for maintenance
ver now it's all subscription
everybody's done that because I mean
certain companies pioneered
it um and they did it for consistency
right because you ended up with this you
know technology companies have these
massively bumpy Revenue curves made them
unpredictable made the you know Wall
Street didn't love it so they adapted
and um
and now we're on the hook for
subscriptions versus you know these
Capital intensive projects that then you
pay maintenance on over many
years so it's that that those days are
gone regardless of whether we like it or
not I just had you just reminded me on
the rims so rims is on
Prem would your project I say your
project but the the Cyber um not
security the cloud that you just talked
about um would that would you be able to
convert like a rims that's currently on
premise to a cloud or would a
rims software or fast you know have to
do something like that like is that
something like that we could do I think
it's yes to both right because we would
we would work with the Department of
Revenue to make sure that whatever we
thought were best practices were
included in whatever agreement they
develop to move to their you know their
ongoing solution in the cloud and then
I'm sure the vendor would be engaged to
do a lot of the
work has there been any discussions yet
about um any moving to the cloud with I
me I feel like room was just started and
it's part of believe that it could be
three to five years ago but is that
something um well you know I always ask
this question and you may have heard me
asking in for over the years when we
were talking about to them um I'd always
say you know what's your what's your
stance on your on-prem versions are you
still upgra updating them you you know
finally after many years infor said well
we're really not investing in our arm
Prem Solutions anymore it's only Cloud
Suite we're investing in and that tells
you oh I better make plans to get there
if I'm going to keep using this system
and fast just recently did the same
thing so we're not feeling pressure to
do anything I don't think but when they
fess up and say oh yeah you know our
direction is to go this way then you
kind of know you know where you're going
to end end up if you stay with that
solution and the fast solution I think
you know the revenue folks would say has
been a huge success for
them I have one final question which is
um this notion as as everyone you know
the state has a
longterm you know as we as we buy a
service we buy software as a service and
and we move into that there's a there's
a thing where I'm you know I'm
committing to you know 10 years let's
say a million dollars a year or 5 years
at 200 Grand a year whatever it is um
before I do that so and and the
accountants are catching up with this
right the gby whatever the hell it was
this year um has the software of service
that we now have to report on
separately um if I do that if I'm an
agency and I'm buying a making a
long-term software commitment that that
isn't I'm not just buying Windows 98 I'm
I'm signing on for eight years do I need
your
approval and so centrally Duit knows the
state's
exposure yeah I mean I know it's not
perfect because we're in early stages
you know all the
contracts come through me or supposed to
occasionally agency you know
occasionally we'll see something I'll
get it you know I get a write up from my
from my team before each governor and
council meeting and well this one never
every once in a while there's a little
this one never came before doit but
here's what it is and so I get a write
up of all of my ours the ones we bring
forward plus all the ones the agencies
are bringing forward and how it sits how
what kind of due diligence we've done on
it and how we feel about it but I I
approve all of those before they before
they come and sometimes you know some uh
it gets to me kind of late
so um you know when I first started in
2015 I was like I had to do a lot of
research before I approved anything
because I didn't know what stuff was now
I kind of been around a while and I know
what's going when in the agencies I know
what the projects are I kind of cons
sense um you know right away whether I
would approve something or not and
typically what I'll do is early before
it comes to me if I'm if I have issues
with a project I will say gee you know
I'll talk to people about it and say you
know let's how about changing this and
if there's push back I
will sometimes say GE you know I don't
know if I can approve this when it comes
to me if we don't do something different
here particularly and what are things
that get me going cyber security data
privacy stuff um you know long-term
stability thoughts you know like I had
one was a while back that was like yeah
well we want to save money by putting it
on a server in our office very sens very
sensitive data and I'm like uh no we're
not going to do that yeah yes it is more
expensive to put a a server in my in the
data center our data center Center in 27
Hazen and back it up and have physical
protections and have all the compliance
stuff that we do yeah that's more
expensive but that's what we have to do
as a state particularly for some of just
really sensitive data so so it's you
know that that's those are the kind of
discussions but honestly we don't have
too much trouble with that it's I think
New Hampshire
has maybe the most uh the highest level
collaboration between it and the
agencies that I've
observed um you know you know spending
time nine years with my peers around the
country I I feel good about being here
on a lot of days when I hear some of the
elsewhere any other
questions thank you very much all right
thank you that being the uh last
presentation of the afternoon we are now
uh recessed until tomorrow morning at